This episode is brought to you by CIBC. From closing that first sale to opening a second store, as a business owner, you've hustled to accomplish a lot, but the rewards don't stop there. When you earn two times more points on things that matter to you and your business, easily track those business expenses and experience flexible Aventura rewards, you'll realize how much more rewarding your hustle can be. Get up to $1,800 in value when you apply for the CIBC Aventura Visa for Business at cibc.com slash Aventura Business. Terms and
本集由 CIBC 赞助播出。从完成第一笔销售到开办第二家分店，作为企业主，你一直在努力成就一番大事业，但回报远不止于此。当你通过对你和你的业务至关重要的事情赚取双倍积分，轻松追踪这些商业支出并体验灵活的 Aventura 回报时，你会发现你的奋斗可以带来多么丰厚的回报。申请 CIBC Aventura 商业 Visa 卡，即可获得价值高达 1,800 美元的优惠，网址为 cibc.com 斜杠 Aventura Business。条款和
conditions apply. What does possible sound like for your business? It's more cash on hand to grow with up to 55 interest-free days. Redefine possible with Business Platinum. That's the powerful backing of American Express. Terms and conditions apply. Visit mx.ca slash business platinum. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
条件适用。您的企业听到“可能”这个词会作何感想？通过长达 55 天的免息期，提供更多流动资金来促进发展。用 Business Platinum 重新定义无限可能。这是美国运通强大的后盾。条款和条件适用。访问 mx.ca 斜杠 business platinum。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hello. Hey, good morning.
现在，我们专门为你带来了终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。你好。嘿，早安。
Good morning. Today we're talking about a pretty fantastic episode. It's Paper Plane. I had forgotten about it. It's Paper Airplane. You know what Paper Plane is? That's the drink I like so much. That's the cocktail. It's not. You know what paper plane is? That's the drink I like so much. That's the cocktail.
早安。今天我们讨论的是一集非常精彩的节目。就是《纸飞机》。我都快忘了。是《纸飞机》。你知道什么是纸飞机吗？那是我非常喜欢的饮品。那是鸡尾酒。不是。你知道什么是纸飞机吗？那是我非常喜欢的饮品。那是鸡尾酒。
Is it really? Yeah. Is it a cocktail? It's called a paper plane. And you know what? I think I'm a lady who would really like a cocktail right now. And that's why I said it. It's been a morning already.
真的吗？是的。这是鸡尾酒吗？它叫纸飞机。你知道吗？我觉得我现在是一个非常想要一杯鸡尾酒的女士。这就是我这么说的原因。今天这一天过得真快。
It has. The entire city of New York helped me get here today because we are recording in different places today. Yes, this is the beauty of podcasting. When we are in two different cities, we can still do the podcast and I love it. We can't tell you why we're in two different cities right now or why we're doing this podcast right now, which is a little off our recording schedule, but we're doing it because Angela Kinsey has the most exciting news
确实如此。今天纽约市的全体市民都在帮我来到这里，因为我们今天在不同的地方录音。是的，这就是播客的魅力所在。当我们身处两个不同的城市时，我们仍然可以录制播客，我太喜欢了。我们不能告诉你为什么我们现在身处两个不同的城市，或者为什么我们现在要录制这个播客，这有点脱离了我们的录制计划，但我们这么做是因为安吉拉·金西带来了有史以来最令人兴奋的
of all time. I'm so excited for you. This is a bucket list item that you're gonna be doing. This is a bucket list item. My mom is over the moon. That's a hint for you guys. It's a job that my mom and sisters are really tickled about and so am I.
好消息。我为你感到高兴。这是你一直想完成的心愿单上的一项。这是心愿单上的一项。我妈妈高兴极了。这是给你们的一个暗示。这份工作让我的妈妈和姐妹们都非常高兴，我也是。
I'm tickled about. So I'm in my closet at 7 a.m. my time, and Jenna is in New York City at the Odyssey Studios at 10 a.m. her time. Cassie is in Florida. That's right, we got Florida Cassie today. At 10 a.m. her time. And we have the Odyssey engineer, Sean, helping us out
我很高兴。所以我现在在我家的时间早上 7 点的衣橱里，珍娜则在她家的时间早上 10 点在纽约市的奥德赛工作室。卡西在佛罗里达州。没错，我们今天有佛罗里达卡西。在她时间早上 10 点。我们有奥德赛的工程师肖恩来帮助我们
as we pull this all together. Thank you guys. And the entire city of New York that helped me get here when my train wouldn't stop at my station. And then we have engineer Sean helping us out as we pull this all together. Thank you, guys. And the entire city of New York that helped me get here when my train wouldn't stop at my station. Lots of people gave me directions. So thank you, New Yorkers. And we're here to talk about paper airplane,
把这一切组合在一起。谢谢你们。还有纽约市的全体市民，当我的火车没有在我那一站停下时，是他们帮我来到这里的。然后我们有工程师肖恩来帮助我们把这一切组合在一起。谢谢你们。还有纽约市的全体市民，当我的火车没有在我那一站停下时，是他们帮我来到这里的。很多人给我指路。所以谢谢你们，纽约人。我们在这里是为了讨论纸飞机，
which is season nine, episode 21, written by Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan and directed by Jesse Peretz. How about a summary? You got it. Here it is. The Scranton branch competes in a paper airplane competition revealing Aaron's competitive side
也就是第九季第二十一集，由沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特德·沙利文编剧，杰西·佩雷茨执导。来个总结怎么样？没问题。就是这样。斯克兰顿分公司参加了纸飞机比赛，展现出了埃林好胜的一面
and Dwight's softer side. Andy has his first acting gig and receives on-set support from Daryl. Meanwhile, Jim and Pam continue working on their marriage. Thank you for saying that. I see your support and I appreciate you doing it. And that's my truth. I see what you're doing. Well played.
和德怀特温柔的一面。安迪迎来了他的第一场表演工作，并得到了达里尔的现场支持。与此同时，吉姆和帕姆继续努力维系他们的婚姻。谢谢你这么说。我看到了你的支持，我很感激你这么做。这就是我的实话。我看到你在做什么了。干得漂亮。
Fast fact number one. This episode was written by Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan. And guess what? We reached out to them and they gave us some wonderful tidbits about this episode. They always come through. I love them. And the very first question that I had to ask was, where did you get the idea for a paper airplane contest? Because I just loved it. Yeah, it reminded me of early days, right? Like, Office Olympics. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Well, Warren said that Halstead had the idea of a paper airplane contest. He said, years prior, the writers were brainstorming for an episode and they wanted the focus to
趣味事实一。这一集由沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特德·沙利文编剧。你猜怎么着？我们联系了他们，他们为我们提供了一些关于这一集的精彩小花絮。他们总是说到做到。我爱死他们了。我必须问的第一个问题是，你从哪里得到了纸飞机比赛的点子？因为我太喜欢了。是的，这让我想起了早期，对吧？比如办公室奥运会。是的。嗯哼。好吧，沃伦说霍尔斯特德想到了纸飞机比赛的点子。他说，多年前，编剧们正在为一个剧集集思广益，他们希望重点
be maybe various ways in which paper could potentially hurt or kill someone. This was their pitch session. And so they had some ideas like, oh, what about a paper cut to the neck? Or maybe Dwight is making a serrated knife out of paper. Oh gosh. Someone even pitched that it was discovered that the Scranton Strangler used Dunder Mifflin paper
放在纸张可能伤害或杀死某人的各种潜在方式上。这就是他们的提案会议。所以他们有一些想法，比如，哦，脖子上被纸割伤怎么样？或者德怀特用纸制作一把锯齿状的刀？哦天哪。甚至有人提出，有人发现斯克兰顿扼杀者用邓德米夫林公司的纸
to fashion a rope to strangle his victims. Mifflin paper to fashion a rope to strangle his victims. Eventually, they settled on a paper airplane contest. And Halstead confirmed that he did pitch this idea way back in season five when they joined the writer's room. He said it just sat on a card on the wall all the way until season nine. Halstead said that when he was in law school in Boston, he saw a local news report about a paper airplane contest
来制作绳索勒死他的受害者。米夫林公司的纸来制作绳索勒死他的受害者。最终，他们决定举办纸飞机比赛。霍尔斯特德证实，早在第五季他们加入编剧室时，他就提出了这个想法。他说它就一直贴在墙上的卡片上，直到第九季。霍尔斯特德说，当他在波士顿读法学院时，他看到了一篇关于麻省理工学院纸飞机比赛的当地新闻报道
at MIT. And they had all these crazy looking planes made by insanely smart engineering students. And they would fly really far and do a bunch of tricks. So when they were looking for story ideas about paper, he thought it seemed pretty natural that a paper company would sponsor a paper airplane contest.
。他们有各种由极其聪明的工程系学生制作的疯狂飞机。它们可以飞得很远并表演各种特技。因此，当他们在寻找关于纸的故事情节创意时，他认为一家造纸公司赞助纸飞机比赛是一件很自然的事情。
I mean, I believe it. Right? It feels like a no brainer. He also said that when they got to season nine, they started pitching on storylines to further the Dwight Angela story. And they really liked how this paper airplane contest paired with Dwight and Angela's arc.
我的意思是，我相信。对吧？感觉这是一个显而易见的选择。他还说，当他们进入第九季时，他们开始构思故事情节来推进德怀特和安吉拉的故事线。他们真的很喜欢纸飞机比赛与德怀特和安吉拉的发展轨迹完美契合。
They loved this idea that Angela had fallen on hard times, that she really needed this money, and that Dwight might try to somehow help her win. Well, we asked them lots of other questions, and we're gonna be sharing their answers throughout the episode. Now, fast fact number two. New director alert, Jesse Peretz. It was
他们非常喜欢这个想法：安吉拉陷入了困境，她真的很需要这笔钱，而德怀特可能会设法帮她赢得比赛。好吧，我们问了他们很多其他问题，我们将在整集中分享他们的回答。现在，趣味事实二。新导演警报，杰西·佩雷茨。在这里接近剧集尾声时拥有一个新的导演充满活力的氛围很有趣
fun to have a new director energy here near the end of the show and here's a little fun fact about Jesse. He was one of the founding members of the Cambridge Massachusetts rock band the Lemonheads. He was the bass player. Did you find that in your digging? Because I didn't know that when we filmed this, I probably would have been a little bit dorkier around him. You know, more dorky than I normally am. I didn't know this at the time either. You know why?
，这里有一个关于杰西的有趣小事实。他是马萨诸塞州剑桥市摇滚乐队柠檬头乐队的创始成员之一。他是贝斯手。你在挖掘资料时发现这个了吗？因为我们拍摄的时候我不知道，如果我知道的话，我在他面前可能会显得有点呆。你知道，比我平时还要呆。我当时也不知道。你知道为什么吗？
We weren't ladies that Googled back then. We were not. The deep diving parts of ourselves have been brought out through this podcast. Because there was Google then. Yes, there was Google then. Yes, there was Google. It's like part of my brain still thinks this Google phenomenon
我们那时候可不是会用谷歌搜索的女士。我们不是。通过这个播客，我们内心深处潜藏的部分被激发出来了。因为那时已经有谷歌了。是的，那时已经有谷歌了。是的，有谷歌。这就像我大脑的一部分仍然认为谷歌这种现象
happened just like the other day. I know, just like a few years ago. Just a few years ago. Well, I guess he left the band right before their breakthrough album. But he continued to work with them as a photographer and a music video director. And he went on to direct videos for the Foo Fighters where he actually won a Grammy for best music video for Learn to Fly. And he's directed a bunch of other
就像前几天才发生的一样。我知道，就像几年前一样。就在几年前。好吧，我想他在乐队取得重大突破之前就退出了。但他继续作为摄影师和音乐录影带导演与他们合作。后来他继续为喷火战机乐队执导MV，并凭借《Learn to Fly》实际上赢得了格莱美最佳音乐录影带奖。他还执导了一堆其他
music videos and now he directs film and television. But I thought maybe just because it's fun, we might want to listen to an audio clip of the Lemonheads song, Into Your Arms. I mean, it is a Saturday after all for us. I know, I need a paper plane. Let's nice. I like it. I like it. I like it.
音乐录影带，现在他执导电影和电视。但我想也许只是为了好玩，我们可能想听一段柠檬头乐队歌曲《Into Your Arms》的音频片段。我的意思是，对我们来说毕竟是星期六。我知道，我需要一架纸飞机。太好了。我喜欢。我喜欢。我喜欢。
All right. I'm going to let that song move us to fast fact number three. It's a fan question from Marie K in Elmira, New York. Marie says, Jenna, I hope you have a deep dive on paper airplanes. I need to know what the furthest recorded distance a paper airplane has flown is. Oh, Marie, I just want you to know how tickled this question made Jenna. She was like, what? Let me research. You were very excited. You told me you have some fun deep dive facts. I do. Marie, I'm going to start by telling you the furthest recorded distance that a paper airplane has traveled. But I had so much fun
好吧。我要让这首歌带我们进入趣味事实三。这是一个来自纽约州埃尔米拉的玛丽·K的粉丝提问。玛丽说，珍娜，我希望你对纸飞机有深入的研究。我需要知道纸飞机飞过的最远记录距离是多少。哦，玛丽，我只想让你知道这个问题让珍娜有多高兴。她当时想：什么？让我查查。你当时非常兴奋。你告诉我你有一些有趣的深度挖掘事实。我确实有。玛丽，我将从告诉你纸飞机飞过的最远记录距离开始。但我对研究纸飞机
researching paper airplanes and I have so much to say about them. I'm going to have to sprinkle them in throughout the show. Well, I'm excited. Let's go. Let's hear them. All right. According to the Guinness Book of World Records, the farthest flight by a paper aircraft was achieved in December 2022 in Indiana by Dylan Ruble, Nathan Erickson, and Garrett Jensen.
乐在其中，而且我有太多关于它们的话要说。我必须在整个节目中穿插着讲。好吧，我很兴奋。我们走吧。让我们听听。好的。根据吉尼斯世界纪录大全，纸飞机飞得最远纪录是 2022 年 12 月在印第安纳州由迪伦·鲁贝尔、内森·埃里克森和加勒特·詹森共同创造的。
It flew 290 feet, or just over 96 yards. So a football field is 120 yards. This went almost a football field. Thank you. I need the visual reference. Thank you. I did that for you. That was very far. Very far. And here's something I learned when I was deep diving paper airplanes, is that these paper airplane people who try to break these records, they tend to work in groups of three. So there's someone who designs the plane, someone who folds it, and then someone who throws it. And all three people get the record. Wow. These guys spent more than 400 hours over a six-month period perfecting their designs. It took 20 minutes to fold the design
它飞了 290 英尺，也就是刚超过 96 码。所以一个美式足球场是 120 码。这个几乎飞了一个足球场。谢谢。我需要视觉参考。谢谢。我是为你这么做的。那真的很远。非常远。当我深入研究纸飞机时，我学到的一点是，这些试图打破这些纪录的纸飞机爱好者们，他们往往以三人为一组进行工作。所以有人设计飞机，有人折叠飞机，然后有人投掷飞机。这三个人都能创下纪录。哇。这些人花了一百多个小时
and they used a single sheet of paper. In fact, there's rules. Yeah, yeah, I was gonna say, is there a rule? Is it like, you can only have one piece of paper, you can't have add-ons, like what are the rules? That's right, the maximum size paper allowed is A4 and the maximum paper density is 100 grams slash M squared. Here's the thing. There's more rules.
在六个月的时间里完善他们的设计。折叠这个设计花了20分钟，他们只用了一张纸。事实上，是有规则的。是的，是的，我正要说，有什么规则吗？比如，你只能用一张纸，不能有附加组件，规则是什么？没错，允许使用的最大纸张尺寸是 A4，最大纸张密度是 100 克每平方米。问题是。还有更多规则。
Oh. You cannot use any glue. You cannot cut the paper. You cannot tear the paper. Kevin, you're out. You're out, Kevin. I know. However, you can use one small piece of clear tape. It can be 25 millimeters by 30 millimeters. Interesting. Also, in order to count for the record, you have to throw the plane indoors behind a starting line.
哦。你不能使用任何胶水。你不能剪纸。你不能撕纸。凯文，你出局了。你出局了，凯文。我知道。不过，你可以使用一小片透明胶带。尺寸可以是 25 毫米乘 30 毫米。有趣的是。此外，为了让记录有效，你必须在室内起跑线后面投掷飞机。
So you can't have any extra wind in your sails. Exactly. If your foot crosses the line line you will be disqualified. So where were they that they threw this paper airplane over a football field and they were indoors? I looked at a number of videos and they have sort of like these giant indoor stadiums or warehouses. Oh. And that's where they set up these record breaking contests. OK. Well, I think we should take a break.
所以你不能借助额外的风势。正是如此。如果你的脚踩过线，你就会被取消资格。那么他们在哪里把这个纸飞机扔过一个足球场而且是在室内呢？我看了好几个视频，他们有那种巨大的室内体育场或仓库。哦。这就是他们设立这些破纪录比赛的地方。好吧，我想我们该休息一下了。
But like I said, everyone, I think you're going to want to stick around because there are way more paper airplane facts coming at you today. And you're not going to want to miss them. You are not going to want to miss them. And guess what? I met and worked with the professional paper airplane people. More on that.
但就像我说的，各位，我想你们会想留下来，因为今天还有更多的纸飞机事实在等着你们。你们肯定不想错过。你们绝对不想错过。你猜怎么着？我遇到并合作了专业的纸飞机达人。更多内容。
No one's gonna be with us after the break. I should have said I brought in paper planes for us to sample. Then everyone would stay. And now I'm mad I didn't. Oh, gosh. Well, I can't wait to hear more about it. We'll be right back Well, we are back let's break down this episode
休息后没有人会跟我们在一起。我本该说我带了纸飞机让我们来品尝。那样大家就会留下来了。现在我很生气我没这么做。哦，天哪。好吧，我迫不及待想听更多关于这方面的内容了。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，让我们来剖析这一集。
It starts at front reception with Clark and Toby coming in. Toby has an eyepatch on, and Clark says, the champions are arriving to the office. And then he goes up to Erin. He's like taunting her. He's like, did you get good sleep last night? Because I'm going to be haunting you in your nightmares. And she's like, oh, yeah. Erin, already out of the gate, is like really aggressive. She has an intensity we have not seen before.
故事从前台开始，克拉克和托比走了进来。托比戴着眼皮眼罩，克拉克说，冠军们正在来到办公室。然后他走向埃林。他就像在挑衅她。他说，昨晚睡得好吗？因为我会在你的噩梦中缠着你。她说，哦，是的。埃林一出场就非常具有攻击性。她表现出了一种我们从未见过的强度。
That's right. This is true. This is when Dwight is going to explain that they're having a branch-wide paper airplane contest. It's sponsored by Wirehammer Paper Company. And it's a tactic to get Dunder Mifflin to sell more of their paper.
没错。这是真的。这时德怀特要解释说他们正在举办一场全分公司范围的纸飞机比赛。由威尔锤造纸公司赞助。这是为了让邓德米夫林卖出更多纸张的策略。
I'll have you know the company Wirehammer is not real. Matt Flynn made the logo for us, and Phil Shea made the fakie reams of paper. Nellie has a talking head where she says there are six brave aviators that are competing, relying on skill, showmanship, and utter confusion. And as she's saying this, there's a montage of Kevin throwing a paper airplane,
我得告诉你，威尔锤公司不是真的。马特·弗林为我们制作了标志，菲尔·谢伊制作了假的纸。内莉有一段访谈镜头，她说有六位勇敢的飞行员正在参赛，依靠的是技巧、表演才能和彻底的混乱。就在她说话的时候，剪辑画面显示凯文扔了一架纸飞机，
then Dwight is trying to knock an apple off the top of Nate's head with a paper airplane, then Dwight is trying to knock an apple off the top of Nate's head with a paper airplane, and then Creed just throws a cantaloupe. Like, no reason. Like, it's a paper airplane contest and Creed chunks a cantaloupe. What's happening, Creed? Well, inspired by Creed's cantaloupe throwing, I thought you might like to know the most paper airplanes thrown into a watermelon in one minute? Wait, I'm sorry. You throw a paper airplane into an open, like a cut open watermelon? I guess so. It's a Guinness Book of World Record.
然后德怀特试图用纸飞机击落内特头顶上的苹果，然后德怀特试图用纸飞机击落内特头顶上的苹果，接着克里德直接扔了一个哈密瓜。就像，无缘无故。就像，这是一场纸飞机比赛，而克里德扔了个哈密瓜。克里德，你在干什么？好吧，受到克里德扔哈密瓜的启发，我想你可能会想知道一分钟内将最多纸飞机扔进西瓜里是多少个？等等，抱准。把纸飞机扔进一个切开的西瓜里？我想是的。这是吉尼斯世界纪录。
How did this become? How? How? Like what? I feel like these are the things from like someone had a few beers. Yeah. Here's the answer. The answer is 13. You can throw 13 paper airplanes into a watermelon. In one minute. And then inspired by Dwight trying to knock the apple off Nate's head, I thought you might like to know the most consecutive times a paper airplane has hit a target. Yes, I do want to know this one. 13 again. Same.
这怎么会变成这样？怎么会？怎么会？像什么？我觉得这些都是某人喝了几杯啤酒后做出的事。是的。答案是。答案是 13 个。你可以把 13 架纸飞机扔进西瓜里。在一分钟内。然后受到德怀特试图击落内特头顶上的苹果的启发，我想你可能会想知道纸飞机连续击中目标的最多次数。是的，我确实想知道这个。又是 13 次。同样。
13 and 13. Okay. Well. Those and 13. OK. Well, those are facts you can now forget, because you'll never need to use them. I was wondering when I would bring up, do you know that you can throw paper airplanes into an open watermelon? And it's in the Guinness Book of Records.
13 和 13。好吧。这些和 13。好吧。这些是你现在可以忘记的事实，因为你永远不需要用到它们。我当时在想我什么时候会提出来，你知道你可以把纸飞机扔进切开的西瓜里吗？而且它在吉尼斯世界纪录里。
Is that coming up at a cocktail party? Now it might. It might. What if someone served watermelon, and you're really at a loss for what to say? You need some small talk. You could say, you know, I know something about watermelons. I sure do.
这会在鸡尾酒会上被提起吗？现在可能会了。可能会。如果有人端上西瓜，而你真的不知道该说些什么呢？你需要一些闲聊的话题。你可以说，你知道，我知道一些关于西瓜的事。我当然知道。
You can throw a paper airplane into them. Okay. Where are we? Well, Pam's going to throw her airplane. We're coming up on a stunt. This is a stunt, you guys. Safety meeting. Mm hmm. Paper airplane traveling at a stunt. This is a stunt, you guys. Safety meeting. Paper airplane traveling at a person.
你可以把纸飞机扔进去。好吧。我们现在在哪里？好吧，帕姆要扔她的飞机了。我们即将迎来一个特技。这是一个特技，伙计们。安全会议。嗯哼。纸飞机冲向一个特技。这是一个特技，伙计们。安全会议。纸飞机冲向一个人。
Pam is gonna throw her plane just as Toby wanders into her flight path. And she hits him right in the eye. And she's like, why didn't you say you were crossing? But didn't he, lady? Did he? He did. He says, hey, I left my glasses down here somewhere,
帕姆要扔她的飞机，正好托比闲逛走进了她的飞行路线。她正中他的眼睛。她说，你为什么不说你要过马路？但她没有吗，女士？她有吗？她有。他说，嘿，我把眼镜落在这附近某处了，
crossing through, beep, beep. He says, beep, beep. Then she throws it and he goes, ow. And she says, I didn't see you. You should have yelled crossing. And Toby's like, I'm sorry. And I'm like, oh my, he did. He literally said.
穿过去，哔哔。他说，哔哔。然后她扔了出去，他说，哎哟。她说，我没看见你。你应该大喊“借过”的。托比说，对不起。我说，哦天哪，他真的说了。
He mumbled it. He tobed it though. He like swallowed it while he was, I'm crossing beep beep. Like come on. I heard the beep beep and I went back and I was like, he totally said it. If you're playing golf, you don't go, four beep beep.
他含糊不清地说了。不过他是以托比的方式说的。他把它吞了下去，当他，我要过马路，哔哔。就像，拜托。我听到了哔哔声，然后我倒回去心想，他完全说出来了。如果你在打高尔夫球，你不会说，四，哔哔。
You're like four. You know what I'm saying? I know, but I thought the beep beep. Like make your presence known, Toby. Okay, all right. But we got a fan question from Ryan S in Massachusetts said, in the cold open when Panther is her plane, is that CGI special effects, or did Jenna really have to practice throwing a paper plane
你会说“四”。你知道我在说什么吗？我知道，但我觉得那个哔哔声。让别人知道你的存在，托比。好吧，好吧。但我们收到了来自马萨诸塞州 Ryan S 的一个粉丝提问，他在冷场开场时，帕姆扔她的飞机时，那是 CGI 特效，还是珍娜真的不得不练习把纸飞机直接扔进
right into Paul's eye? Well, Ryan, I really did throw a paper airplane, but the part where it hit Toby was visual effects. So here's what we did. This was three different shots that we put all together. So the first thing we did was an angle on me throwing a plane. Then we shot a paper airplane flying through the air that was thrown by a professional, not by me, toward nothing.
保罗的眼睛里？嗯，瑞安，我确实扔了一架纸飞机，但它击中托比的那部分是视觉特效。所以我们是这样做的。这是我们拼凑在一起的三个不同的镜头。所以我们做的第一件事是拍我扔飞机的角度。然后我们拍摄了一架在空中飞行的纸飞机，是由专业人员扔的，不是我扔的，朝着空无一物的地方。
Toby was not standing there. And then we filmed Toby reacting as if he had gotten hit with a paper airplane that he was not standing there. And then we filmed Toby reacting as if he had gotten hit with a paper airplane that he was not hit with. And then we combine all the shots together and it makes it look like he's getting hit in the eye. Did that make sense? It did make sense. You know, Halstead shared with us that even though
托比没有站在那里。然后我们拍摄托比的反应，就好像他被一架他没有站在那里的纸飞机击中了一样。然后我们拍摄托比的反应，就好像他被一架他根本没有被击中的纸飞机击中了一样。然后我们将所有的镜头组合在一起，看起来就像他的眼睛被打中了。这说得通吗？这说得通。你知道，霍尔斯特德跟我们分享过，尽管
it seems like a fairly simple moment, it took two full days to shoot this. So crazy. Crazy. And he also went on to say, I think Pam flying a plane into Toby's eye was one of the first scenes shot. And I remember Jenna saying, I think this is incredibly broad, which let's face it, it's true. Well, because originally, originally, they gave Paul an airplane to like hold between his fingers as if it was stabbing him in the eye. I remember that.
这看起来是一个相当简单的时刻，但拍摄这幕花了整整两天时间。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。他还接着说，我认为帕姆把飞机飞进托比的眼睛是拍摄的第一场戏之一。我记得珍娜当时说，我觉得这太夸张了，让我们面对现实吧，这确实是真的。好吧，因为最初，最初，他们给了保罗一架飞机，让他夹在手指间，就像它刺进他的眼睛里一样。我记得那个。
And I was like, guys, that looks ridiculously broad. I think it became a blooper moment. It did. And then they decided to take that part out. You just see it hits him and falls on the ground. Well, we will share the bloopers and our stories, but here it is for you to hear. How's it look? It looks ridiculously broad.
然后我说，伙计们，这看起来太荒谬了。我觉得这成了一个NG镜头时刻。确实如此。然后他们决定把那部分去掉。你只能看到它击中了他并落在地上。好吧，我们会分享NG镜头和我们的故事，但现在让你们听听看。看起来怎么样？看起来荒谬得夸张。
And we are laughing so hard because it did. He had a cartoonish plane stuck to his head to look like it's coming out his eye. It looked ridiculous. Yes. Thankfully, we changed it. But I guess after the paper airplane hits Toby and lands on the ground, Pam is like, so is this my spot? And she's out of the context.
我们笑得前仰后合，因为确实如此。他头上插着一架卡通飞机，看起来像是从眼睛里钻出来的。看起来太荒谬了。是的。谢天谢地，我们改了。但我想在纸飞机击中托比并落在地上后，帕姆说，那么这是我的位置吗？她完全状况外。
I thought that was very funny. She was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, your eye. Is this where I landed? Well, now they're down to an elite eight. Well, seven and Toby. I want to say Nellie's commentary, her little bits she does, are so funny throughout the whole thing.
我觉得这太搞笑了。她当时说，对，对，对，你的眼睛。这是我着陆的地方吗？好吧，现在他们缩小到精英八强了。好吧，七个人加托比。我想说内莉的解说，她所做的那些小插曲，在整个过程中都太搞笑了。
I loved her little outfit, her little referee outfit. I know. It's looking very cute. I loved that choice. And you know what? This would be a special project. This is her domain. Yes.
我喜欢她的那一套衣服，她的小裁判制服。我知道。看起来非常可爱。我喜欢那个选择。你知道吗？这将是一个特殊的项目。这是她的地盘。是的。
Now we're gonna start Andy's storyline, and I have to do some applause for Ed Helms. He was so hilarious in this episode. I really enjoyed his performance. What's happening is he's running lines with Daryl, and he's going way too big and way too broad for whatever this script is. Daryl saying things like, there's no exclamation point.
现在我们要开始安迪的故事线了，我必须为埃德·赫尔姆斯鼓掌。他在这一集里太搞笑了。我真的很享受他的表演。发生的事情是他正在和达里尔对台词，而他对这个剧本的表现过于夸张和粗糙了。达里尔说诸如“没有感叹号”之类的话。
It's not acidic, like the things he's talking about. And this is when we find out that last week Andy got an agent and this week a movie, the HRPDC chemical handling protocols industrial. And you know what? Andy's like, you never know. Could be seen by Brad Pitt's brother. And then next thing I know, I'm in Moneyballs too.
这并不尖酸刻工，就像他谈论的事情一样。这时我们发现，上周安迪找了一个经纪人，这周接了一部电影，即 HRPDC 化学品处理规程工业宣传片。你知道吗？安迪说，你永远说不准。可能会被布拉德·皮特兄弟看到。然后接下来的事我知道了，我就去拍《点球成金2》了。
So, you know, my first acting job was an industrial, just like Andy, my first paid acting job in Los Angeles where I had lines. You know, my first acting job was as an extra on the Jurassic Park Ride Universal Studios, where I was doused with water for about 12 hours. Oh, gosh. But my first speaking role was in an industrial.
所以，你知道，我的第一份表演工作是一部工业宣传片，就像安迪一样，我在洛杉矶的第一份有台词的有偿表演工作。你知道，我的第一份表演工作是在环球影城侏罗纪公园骑乘项目上担任临时演员，我在那里被水淋了大约 12 个小时。哦，天哪。但我的第一个有台词的角色是在一部工业宣传片里。
Yeah. For the UCLA medical facility. And it was a sex education video for patients upon their release from the hospital. What kind of things did you have to say? I was a girl and I was going on a date and my sister says to me as I'm getting ready to leave, she says, well, have fun on your date. I hope you have protection. And I say, protection? What? Protection from what?
是的。为加州大学洛杉矶分校医疗中心拍的。那是一部针对患者出院时的性教育视频。你得说些什么样的话？我当时是个女孩，我要去约会，当我准备出门时，我姐姐对我说，好吧，祝你约会愉快。我希望你有保护措施。我说，保护措施？什么？防范什么？
And she says, from pregnancy and sexually transmitted diseases, come here. And she's a nurse. She's dressed like a nurse. And she talks about sexually transmitted diseases and various disease. I mostly listen very earnestly. And then at the end, I say something along the lines of, well, now I feel prepared for my date. Like, what is first
她说，防范怀孕和性传播疾病，过来。她是个护士。她打扮得像个护士。她谈到了性传播疾病和各种疾病。我大多非常认真地听着。然后在最后，我说了一些类似这样的话：嗯，现在我觉得为我的约会做好准备了。就像，什么是初次
date? It has high stakes. What is happening? What is happening? I'm also like, it's just coffee. Like, it's going to be fine. And were you like, Andy, were you like, this is my moment? I have arrived. I was very prepared. I knew all my lines, I knew how I was gonna react to all of the diseases.
约会？这风险太高了。发生了什么？发生了什么？我也觉得，这只是喝杯咖啡而已。一切都会好起来的。你当时是不是像安迪一样想，这就是我的时刻？我成功了。我准备得非常充分。我知道我所有的台词，我知道我将如何对所有的疾病做出反应。
I was paid $100 and I did my own hair and makeup. Well, very similar to Andy. He's gonna do his own hair and makeup. It's in a deleted scene. We'll get to it. I'm gonna share it. But you know, I remember one of my first big auditions that I was so excited about was an industrial
我得到了 100 美元的报酬，而且我自己弄了发型和妆容。好吧，和安迪非常相似。他要自己弄发型和妆容。这在一个被剪掉的场景里。我们会讲到。我会分享它。不过你知道，我记得我的第一次大试镜让我非常兴奋，那是为
for Ford motor cars where I would be in a lab coat. The audition, they actually had us read off a teleprompter because they wanted to see if you could do that because there was going to be a lot of that. And I talked about like the new engine and the words coming out of my mouth. I didn't even understand them. And I'm sure no one believed it.
福特汽车公司拍的一部工业宣传片，我在片中要穿着实验白大褂。在试镜时，他们实际上让我们对着提词器朗读，因为他们想看看你能不能做到这一点，因为会有很多这样的内容。我谈论了新引擎什么的，从我嘴里说出来的话。我甚至都听不懂。我敢肯定没有人相信。
I was saying things like, you know, it has twin independent variable camshaft timing. And I was like, I did not get the part, you guys. I did not get it. But it cracked me up that this was Andy's storyline. And I love that Halstead shared this. He said, we knew at the beginning of many actors careers, they could get cast in commercials or corporate industrial films.
我说了一些诸如“你知道，它有双独立可变凸轮轴正时”之类的话。当时我想，我没有得到那个角色，伙计们。我没拿到。但让我感到好笑的是，这是安迪的故事线。我很高兴霍尔斯特德分享了这一点。他说，我们知道在许多演员职业生涯的初期，他们可能会出演广告或企业工业片。
We thought it would be really funny to see Andy get cast in an industrial film, which was super dry and boring, but that Andy would treat it as if it was an Oscar-winning performance. I mean, we all did. We all did. This is all true. Oh, it took me right back to that Ford industrial.
我们认为看到安迪出演一部非常枯燥乏味的工业片会非常有趣，但安迪却会把它当作奥斯卡获奖表演来对待。我的意思是，我们都这样。我们都这样。这一切都是真的。哦，这瞬间把我带回了那个福特的工业片。
Well, I guess all of this is just to say that this is a very accurate depiction of a new actor getting their first role. Yes. Well done. Oh boy now we're gonna move into the Jim and Pam storyline. Oh gosh this made me cringe. There were times where I was really cringing because it felt like this forced exercise that they were really trying to get behind. But man. Pam is really difficult in this episode, isn't she?
好吧，所有这一切都只是为了说明，这非常准确地描绘了一个新演员获得他们的第一个角色时的情景。干得好。哦，天哪，现在我们要进入吉姆和帕姆的故事线了。哦，天哪，这让我感到局促不安。有时我真的感到局促不安，因为感觉像是一种强迫性的练习，他们真的很想支持下去。但天哪。帕姆这一集真的很刁难人，不是吗？
Like, I feel like Jim is being a better team player here, and Pam is, you can see how closed off she is. I mean, later she's going to have a talking head about it. But her truth is she's not ready to forgive him. That's her truth. And she's doing these exercises and it seems like he's really trying. So yeah, you do feel her bumping up against that effort.
就像，我觉得吉姆在这里表现得像个更好的团队合作者，而帕姆，你能看出她是多么封闭自己。我的意思是，后来她会对此有一段访谈镜头。但她的真实想法是她还没有准备好原谅他。那是她的真实想法。而且她正在做这些练习，看起来他真的很努力。所以，是的，你确实能感受到她在抵触这种努力。
But have you ever been in that situation before where like when the other person is finally acknowledging that the situation is sh**ty and they're trying, your first response is kind of like, too little, too late, buddy. Because you haven't been angry yet. You haven't gotten to be mad yet. And so I think that's where Pam is.
但你以前有没有过这种经历，当另一个人终于承认情况一团糟并且他们在努力时，你的第一反应有点像是，伙计，太少，太迟了。因为你还没发过火呢。你还没机会生气呢。所以我想这就是帕姆的处境。
Pam's like finally has permission. She's being seen and she needs to start by being mad. But the first thing she's gonna do is get an apple from the vending machine and that was scripted. That was scripted. I noticed that I got an apple and I was like, that's so weird, we almost never got fruit. But it was scripted that Pam was getting an apple
帕姆就像终于得到了许可。她被看到了，她需要从生气开始。但她要做的第一件事是从自动售货机里拿个苹果，那是剧本写好的。那是剧本写好的。我注意到我拿了一个苹果，我想，太奇怪了，我们几乎从不吃水果。但剧本里写着帕姆要拿个苹果，
and Jim comes and sees her in the break room and they're doing this, you know, couples therapy speak. Yes, they're expressing how much they appreciate one another. And then they have a joint talking head where we find out that they're doing couples therapy. They want to find every opportunity to acknowledge and appreciate one another's sacrifices. And also they have to use the word opportunity for things that they're not super happy about. This made me laugh because I rebrand things like this to my kids. Like things my kids maybe don't want to do, I call them an experiment.
吉姆来休息室看她，他们在进行这种夫妻治疗式的谈话。是的，他们表达了彼此是多么感激对方。然后他们有一个联合访谈镜头，我们发现他们正在做夫妻治疗。他们希望寻找每一个机会去承认和感谢彼此的牺牲。而且他们必须对那些他们不太开心的事使用“机会”这个词。这逗笑了我，因为我把类似这样的事情重新包装推销给我的孩子。比如我孩子可能不想做的事情，我称之为实验。
I'll be like, Hey kids, I'm experimenting with a new vegetable for dinner tonight. Or I'll be like, hey, as an experiment, I think we're gonna have you guys do the dishes every night this week as an experiment. But I also do that to myself. I'll be like, I'm experimenting with taking a walk every day and then I'm going to analyze how that made my body feel at the end of the week.
我会说，嘿，孩子们，我今晚在尝试一种晚餐的新蔬菜。或者我会说，嘿，作为一个实验，我想这周每天晚上都让你们洗碗，作为一个实验。但我也对自己这样做。我会说，我正在尝试每天散步，然后在周末分析这让我的身体感觉如何。
Somehow, like if I brand it as an experiment, kind of like how they're saying things are opportunities. my body feel at the end of the week. Somehow like if I brand it as an experiment, kind of like how they're saying things are opportunities. Opportunities, yeah. It is funny, it's very, I think, parenting thing to do because I know like sometimes like, if our kids are frustrated with like, oh, we got a new school schedule, you know,
不知何故，如果我把它包装成一个实验，就像他们把事情称为机会一样。让我的身体感觉如何。不知何故，如果我把它包装成一个实验，就像他们把事情称为机会一样。机会，是的。这很有趣，这非常像父母会做的事，因为我知道有时候，如果我们的孩子对诸如“哦，我们有了新的学校日程安排”感到沮丧，你知道，
they're getting their schedules, it's high school. And sometimes the classes don't line up the way they want it. And I'm like, well, you know what? That's information. You just got some information. That's information. So I say that. Or if someone is maybe not as friendly as they had hoped or whatever it is at school,
他们拿到了日程安排，那是高中。有时课程安排不像他们希望的那样。然后我会说，好吧，你知道吗？那是信息。你刚刚得到了一些信息。那是信息。所以我这么说。或者如果有人可能不如他们所希望的那样友好，或者学校里发生了什么，
I'm like, well, that's information you just learned. So I say information. And then it just makes me think of how all these years, all the extra talking heads were called candy bag. The candy bag. You know, we've talked about this, Jenna, and I was always like, Oh, it's the candy bag. And Greg was like, I called it that. So maybe you guys wouldn't be annoyed. I thought, what would my kids like? Ooh, a candy bag. That's right. If it was called the extra work bag, we'd be like, oh, get out the candy bag. It's so true.
我会说，好吧，那是你刚学到的信息。所以我说信息。然后这让我想起这些年来，所有额外的访谈镜头都被称为糖果袋。糖果袋。你知道，我们讨论过这个，珍娜，我总是说，哦，这是糖果袋。格雷格说，我这么叫是为了你们也许不会感到烦恼。我想，我的孩子们会喜欢什么？噢，一个糖果袋。没错。如果它被称为额外工作袋，我们就会想，哦，拿出糖果袋吧。确实如此。
Yeah, there's fun treats in here for you guys. Sorry you have to stay another half an hour. Well, Warren and Halstead said this storyline was based on the experience of one of the writers who had shared about doing couples therapy. This writer helped them come up with all of these exercises. Warren said that one particular phrase really tickled him. It was the, I appreciate you. He said this was something he felt like he'd started to see a lot of NBA athletes say in interviews, and he always felt like it was sort of a subtle code for,
是的，这里面有适合你们的有趣零食。抱歉你们得再多呆半小时。好吧，沃伦和霍尔斯特德说这个故事线是基于其中一位分享过做夫妻治疗经历的编剧。这位编剧帮助他们想出了所有这些练习。沃伦说，有一个特定的短语真正逗乐了他。那就是“我很感激你”。他说这是他觉得开始看到很多 NBA 球员在采访中说的一句话，他总是觉得这某种程度上是以下话语的微妙代名词：
I hate this. Or, I hate you.. Oh I appreciate that question. I appreciate that. I appreciate you asking me about that. Yeah. Well lady I have to tell you when I was looking up this episode you know we do all the things we go back in time we read the shooting draft we look at the call sheets and I always check my digital clutter. And what a treasure trove. I could not believe it. Apparently, the week we filmed this,
我讨厌这个。或者，我讨厌你。。哦，我很感激那个问题。我很感激。我很感激你问我那个问题。好吧，女士，我必须告诉你，当我查找这一集时，你知道我们做了所有的事情，我们回到过去，我们阅读拍摄剧本，我们查看通告单，我总是检查我的数字杂乱。真是个宝藏。我简直不敢相信。显然，我们拍摄这一周，
you and I took our cameras, I took tons of pictures in the warehouse. These are pictures, lady, I have never seen. Not even for our book. I found an old email account. Oh my gosh. I forgot about. And you, I found an email from you to this old email account
你和我拿着相机，我在仓库里拍了大量照片。这些照片，女士，我从未见过。甚至为了我们的书也没有。我发现了一个旧电子邮件账户。哦，天哪。我忘记了。而且你，我发现了一封你发给这个旧电子邮件账户的邮件，
and I was like, oh my gosh. And I was able to get into it and there's all of these photos lady. No, of this episode and more? This episode and more. And in particular, you and I were like oh we've got to document everything. Yes I remember that as we were getting to these last kind of six seven episodes we started bringing our camera to work again. Yes.
当时我想，哦，天哪。我登录进去了，这里全都是这些照片，女士。不，关于这一集的还有别的吗？这一集还有别的！特别是，你和我当时想，哦，我们得记录下一切。是的，我记得随着我们进入最后大约六、七集，我们开始再次把相机带去上班。是的。
A good camera like not just our phone. So many pictures I have started folders now and also I found an email from Greg and I wanted to read it to you. Okay. So this was on February 13th, 2013, 1 31 p.m. You know I like to know the time stamp. You do. It goes back to my travel journaling. He wrote, Hey brilliant cast, we are thinking about putting together a trip to Scranton on May 1st to take a victory lap, promote the last three episodes, and we'd like to shoot a little scene or two for the finale. The people who organized the first office convention are excited to do it.
一个好的相机，不仅仅是我们的手机。我建了好多文件夹，我还发现了一封来自格雷格的邮件，我想读给你听。好的。这是在 2013 年 2 月 13 日下午 1 点 31 分。你知道我喜欢知道时间戳。你确实喜欢。这可以追溯到我的旅行手记。他写道，嘿，才华横溢的演员们，我们正在考虑在 5 月 1 日组织一次去斯克兰顿的旅行，来一次胜利游行，宣传最后三集，我们想为大结局拍一两个小场景。组织第一届办公室大会的人们对此感到非常兴奋。
For those of you who have never been, it's pretty exciting. The police force of the city is marshaled to drive us around and it's a huge deal for everybody that lives there. Last time we attracted 5,000 fans from as far away as Ireland. Please let me know if this could be something you could welcome into your schedule. Also, side note, I want to save all of your desks together, and I think it would make it more special
对于你们中从未去过的人来说，这相当令人兴奋。这座城市的警力出动来带我们四处参观，这对住在那里每个人来说都是一件大事。上次我们吸引了来自远至爱尔兰的 5000 名粉丝。请告诉我这是否是你能安排进日程里的一件事。另外，顺便说一句，我想把你们所有的办公桌放在一起，而且我觉得如果你在办公桌抽屉底部写下一张便条，会更有意义。有人想这么做吗？祝好，格雷格。
if you wrote a note in the bottom of your desk drawer. Anybody want to do that? Best, Greg. Hmm. So we all wrote in our desk drawers. Yeah. And I don't think Greg got our desks. I don't think he did either.
所以我们都在办公桌抽屉里写了字。是的。而且我猜格雷格并没有弄到我们的办公桌。我想他也没有。
After all of that, I remember they wouldn't let him have them. Yeah. Which is a real bummer. And that trip to Scranton ended up getting pushed till later. We didn't film episodes there, but I forgot that we signed our desk drawers for Greg. Every time we go into our digital clutter
经历了这一切之后，我记得他们不肯让他拿走。是的，这真的很令人沮丧。去斯克兰顿的那次旅行最后被推迟了。我们没有在那里拍剧集，但我忘了我们为格雷格在办公桌抽屉里签名了。每次我们查看我们的数字杂乱
and we find these emails from Greg and they say, dear brilliant cast, I get a little choked up because that's how he started all of his emails to us and how he continues to write emails to us. To this day. Yeah. Well, anyway, that was just a little moment back in time. Well, that made me very nostalgic.
然后发现这些来自格雷格的邮件，上面写着“亲爱的才华横溢的演员们”，我都有点哽咽，因为那是他向我们发所有邮件的开头，也是他至今仍然写邮件给我们的方式。直到今天。是的。好吧，不管怎样，那只是回到过去的一个小插曲。好吧，这让我感到非常怀旧。
I know. Let's see, where are we? Oh, Andy is going to announce his new job to the whole bullpen. And he's going to tell Oscar that he's going to use Oscar's recent breakup with the senator for inspiration if he needs to get emotional. And Oscar's like, why don't you just use your own life?
我知道。让我们看看，我们现在在哪儿？哦，安迪要向整个大办公室宣布他的新工作。他要告诉奥斯卡，如果他需要表现出情感，他将从奥斯卡最近与参议员分手的事情中汲取灵感。奥斯卡说，你为什么不利用你自己的生活呢？
Aaron just broke up with you. And he's like, hey, too raw, buddy. All right? Not cool. Well, next, Nellie is going to enter with a rep from Wirehammer Paper and he's carrying a giant check. I love a giant check.
埃林刚刚和你分手了。他说，嘿，太戳痛处了，伙计。好吗？这很不酷。好吧，接下来，内莉将与一位来自威尔锤造纸公司的代表一起进场，他拿着一张巨型支票。我喜欢巨型支票。
I would love to win a giant check. Doesn't everyone want a giant check handed to them sometimes? I would love to present a giant check, receive a giant check, and then where do you take the giant check? Do you take it to the bank? I've wondered this my whole life. Who do you hand the giant check to? Do you have to sign the back of it to the bank? I've wondered this my whole life. Well, in the- Who do you hand the giant check to?
我也想赢得一张巨型支票。难道每个人有时都想有人递给自己一张巨型支票吗？我很乐意颁发一张巨型支票，收到一张巨型支票，然后你把巨型支票带到哪里去？你要把它带到银行吗？我一辈子都在想这个。你把巨型支票交给谁？你必须在背面签名交给银行吗？我一辈子都在想这个。好吧，在……你把巨型支票交给谁？
Do you have to sign the back of it? What happens? In the movie, Happy Gilmore, he has all those giant checks in his backseat of his car because he keeps winning them at the golf tournaments. And I don't know, I think this is a universal thing. Yeah. Does anyone know what you do with the giant check?
你非得在上面签名吗？会发生什么？在电影《快乐吉尔莫》中，他的汽车后座上放着一堆巨型支票，因为他在高尔夫锦标赛上不断赢得奖金。而且我觉得，这似乎是个普遍现象。是的。有人知道你怎么处理巨型支票吗？
Will you tell us if you've won one? I want to take it to the bank. Me too. I want to walk in with it and like, awkwardly try to open the door and fit through it with my giant check. And then walk up to the teller and try to wedge it in the little hole where you put your money in.
你能跟我们说说你是不是赢过一张吗？我想把它拿到银行去。我也是。我想拿着它走进去，然后笨拙地试着开门，带着我的巨型支票挤过去。接着走到柜台前，试图把它塞进存钱的小洞里。
I know. All of these things. I know. I think it's why they're so popular. We all want one. We want the big check. This is when they're going to announce the $2,000 cash prize, which apparently no one knew about because Nellie forgot
我知道。所有这些事。我知道。我想这就是它们这么受欢迎的原因。我们都想要一张。我们想要巨额支票。这时他们要宣布2000美元的现金奖，显然没有人知道这件事，因为内莉忘了
to tell them. This changes everything. The whole bullpen flips out. They're like, $2,000? Why didn't you tell us? And she's like, I did? I'm sure I did. And then immediately she's like, nope, I forgot.
告诉他们。这下全变了。整个办公区都抓狂了。他们说：2000美元？你为什么不早说？她却说：我说了吗？我确信我说过。然后她马上又说：没有，我忘了。
Well, the guest star playing Robert from Wirehammer Paper was Todd Aaron Brotsy. And he most recently appeared in Lessons in Chemistry in Curb Your Enthusiasm. And he had recurring roles on Arrested Development and Veep. And you'll see him. He's downstairs with us during the contest. Yeah.
好吧，饰演“电锤纸业”罗伯特的客串演员是托德·亚伦·布罗齐。他最近出演了《化学课》和《抑制热情》。他在《发展受阻》和《副总统》中也有常驻角色。你会看到他的。在比赛期间，他就在楼下和我们在一起。是的。
He's overseeing the whole thing. Up next is an Angela talking head. And I have quite a bit to share about it. I have quite a bit to share about it. And it got a fan mail flurry. Where do we begin? Oh, wow. Why don't we start with me reading exactly what it said?
他在监督整个活动。接下来是安吉拉的单独采访。关于这个我有不少想分享的。我有很多想分享的。这引发了一波粉丝来信热潮。我们从哪里开始呢？哦，天哪。为什么不从我一字不差地朗读信里的内容开始呢？
Okay. Okay. Okay. So there is a montage happening underneath this talking head of Angela and her apartment with her cats and a very upset Philip. And Angela says, me? Oh, I'm fine. I mean, sure, times are leaner now that I'm separated from the senator, but my new studio apartment is just fine for me and Philip and
好的。好的。好的。所以在这个单独采访的画面下方，穿插着安吉拉和她的猫咪们以及一个非常崩溃的菲利普的蒙太奇。安吉拉说：我？哦，我很好。我是说，当然，自从我和参议员分居后，日子过得比较紧巴，但我的新单身公寓对我、菲利普、
Tinky and crinkle puss and bandit two and Pollock Baggins and Lady Aragon and their ten kittens. I Had a chance with Dwight But I didn't take it and if I went back now when I'm broke and he just inherited a farm I'd be one of those gold digging tramps you read about that tried to bag a farmer Okay, I have so many things to say number one. Isn't there a reality show where that tried to bag a farmer. Okay. I have so many things to say. Number one, isn't there a reality show where you try to bag a farmer? It's a show where there's like handsome bachelor farmers. Sean is nodding yes. Sean, have you seen Marry a Farmer? What's it called? I think it's called Farmer Needs a Wife. I haven't seen it. Oh my God. Yes. Farmer needs a wife, that's it.
丁基、皱褶脸、强盗二世、波洛克·巴金斯、阿拉贡夫人以及它们十只小猫来说刚刚好。我有机会和德怀特在一起，但我没有把握。如果我现在身无分文却回去找他，而他刚刚继承了一个农场，我就会成为你在书里读到的那种一心想傍个农场主的拜金女。好吧，我有好多话要说。第一，难道没有什么真人秀节目是专门讲傍个农场主的吗？好吧，我有好多话要说。第一，难道没有什么真人秀节目是讲怎么傍个农场主的吗？这是一个有那种英俊单身汉农场主的节目。肖恩正在点头。肖恩，你看过《嫁给农场主》吗？它叫什么名字？我想它叫《农场主需要个老婆》。我没看过。哦，天哪。是的。农场主需要个老婆，就是这个。
So. I didn't know. I know there's one where you try to date a fireman. Is there one like that? I haven't heard of that one. Sean, anything? Date a fireman? He doesn't know.
所以。我不知道。我知道有个节目是关于试着和消防员约会的。有这样的节目吗？我没听说过那个。肖恩，有什么要说的吗？约会消防员？他不知道。
Okay, maybe not. Okay. What's with all the cat names? I need to talk about them. Did these even come up in our contest with Billie Eilish? No, they did not. Pollock Baggins, crinkle puss, Tinky. Hey now, there's something we need to discuss
好吧，也许没有。好吧。这些猫的名字是怎么回事？我得聊聊它们。这些名字在我们和比利·艾利什的比赛里出现过吗？没有，并没有。波洛克·巴金斯、皱褶脸、丁基。等等，有些事情我们需要讨论一下，
and it's big time. What is it? There are two Lord of the Rings references in these cat names. Is Angela Martin a Lord of the Rings fan? I think so. Pollock Baggins, based on Bilbo Baggins, The Hobbit. Okay. Hello. I'll take your word for it. I have so many things to say about this.
而且这可是个大事。是什么？这些猫的名字里有两个《指环王》的梗。安吉拉·马丁是个《指环王》迷吗？我想是的。波洛克·巴金斯，原型是《霍比特人》里的比尔博·巴金斯。好吧。你好。我暂且信你。关于这个我有太多话要说。
We're going to need to spend some time here. Studio apartment, fine. Why no bed? Why a couch? How about you and Philip sleep in a bed together? I don't know. This apartment was really surprising to me. They built it over on our warehouse set and they really wanted to show that Angela was going through some lean financial times. It was described like this in the shooting draft. Angela forcing a smile, holds a screaming Philip as she shows the camera a studio apartment with a futon, a crib, and a few appliances. Eleven cats wander around. She tries to put Philip down for a second in his crib and continue with the tour, but then notices to her alarm that three cats have immediately laid down on his warm body covering his face. she snatches the baby back up. Well, this brings me to our fan mail flurry. It begins with Jen C. in Mason City, Iowa, who says,
我们得花点时间聊聊这个。单身公寓，挺好。为什么没有床？为什么是个沙发？你和菲利普一起睡在一张床上不好吗？我不知道。这个公寓真的让我大吃一惊。他们在我们的仓库布景里搭了这样一个地方，他们真的很想展现安吉拉正经历着财务窘境。拍摄剧本里是这样描述的：安吉拉强挤出一个微笑，抱着大哭的菲利普，向镜头展示一间单身公寓，里面有一张沙发床、一张婴儿床和几件家电。十一只猫在四周闲逛。她试图把菲利普暂时放下，让他睡在婴儿床里，然后继续介绍，但随后惊恐地发现三只猫立刻趴在了他温暖的身体上，遮住了他的脸。她一把把孩子抱了回来。嗯，这就说到了我们的粉丝来信热潮。信由艾奥瓦州梅森城的珍·C发起，她说：
How does Angela go into such poverty after splitting from the senator who is clearly very well off judging from what we've seen of their home together? Shouldn't she be getting spousal support? And ultimately, wouldn't the senator feel guilty about how he treated her? Also, doesn't Angela seem like the type to have been saving every penny her entire life? The only thing she has ever splurged on was Princess Lady, and that was with the money from selling Andy's engagement ring.
安吉拉在与明显非常有钱的参议员分居后，怎么会陷入如此贫困的境地？从我们见过的他们共同的家来看，她难道不应该获得配偶赡养费吗？归根结底，参议员难道不应该对如何对待她感到内疚吗？另外，安吉拉难道不像是那种一生中每一分钱都省着花的人吗？她唯一挥霍过的一次就是公主女士，那还是用卖掉安迪订婚戒指的钱。
I just can't with this storyline every time I get to it. Am I the only one who has a hard time with this? Jen, no. Allie P from Rexburg, Idaho also has a hard get to it, am I the only one who has a hard time with this? Jen, no. Allie P from Rexburg, Idaho also has a hard time with it and said this, before Angela got married, it seemed like she did pretty well for herself and lived comfortably. Logistically, she should be making more due to raises
每次看到这个剧情线我都实在受不了。难道我是唯一一个觉得这剧情很难接受的人吗？珍，不是的。爱达荷州雷克斯堡的艾莉·P也觉得很难接受，并这样说道：在安吉拉结婚之前，她似乎把自己的生活过得相当不错，也很舒适。按逻辑来说，随着加薪，
and such, so why is she suddenly unable to support herself? Do you think it was just the added cost of a child and everything that comes with that? Also, did Angela tell Robert that Philip may not be his son or is he just abandoning a child he believes to be his own? He should be paying some sort of child support, since it appears they have officially divorced. I'm sure this was just a way for the writers to get Angela and Oscar back to being friends,
她应该赚得更多才对，那为什么她突然无法养活自己了？你认为这只是因为多了一个孩子的开销以及随之而来的一切吗？另外，安吉拉有没有告诉罗伯特，菲利普可能不是他的亲生儿子？还是说他只是在抛弃一个他认为是自己骨肉的孩子？既然他们看起来已经正式离婚了，他应该支付某种抚养费才对。我敢肯定这只是编剧让安吉拉和奥斯卡重归于好的手段，
but what is going on here? They would both love to hear your thoughts, Angela. Oh, I have so many similar thoughts, ladies. One of the things I do want to share is in the shooting draft, Angela's talking head was slightly longer. OK. She had a line where she said, I guess I should have read that prenup a little closer
但这里到底是怎么回事？安吉拉，她们俩都很想听听你的想法。哦，我有好多类似的感想，女士们。我想分享的一点是，在拍摄剧本中，安吉拉的单独采访其实要稍微长一点。好的。她有一句台词是：我想我在签字之前应该更仔细地阅读那份婚前协议的。
before signing it. Yeah. That would have helped so much to explain what was going on. Yes, so I guess there was a prenup and who knows what all it said, but Angela did not pay close attention to it and she just signed it.
是的。那会对解释当时的情况有很大帮助。是的，所以我想当时确实有一份婚前协议，鬼知道里面都写了些什么，但安吉拉没有仔细看，她就直接签字了。
And that in itself doesn't even seem like her. No. She's a very thorough person, but maybe she was just so, you know, kind of dazzled by the idea of being a senator's wife in her mind, right? Sure. And then the only other thing I can think of is that,
这本身就不太符合她的性格。不符合。她是个非常严谨的人，但也许她当时被“当上参议员夫人”这个念头给迷昏了头，心里这么想的吧？当然。然后我能想到的唯一一件事就是，
you know, starting fresh again and getting an apartment and first and last month's rent and having a child, like that maybe she is starting out smaller than what she used to have. And as far as the Senator, I have my own little backstory that I've never shared. Oh, that I gave myself to help all of it make sense and ring true for me is that Angela and the Senator know that Philip was not his all along. They always knew it.
你知道的，重新开始生活，租一套公寓，付首月和末月的房租，还要养个孩子，可能她现在起步的条件比以前要差。至于参议员，我有一个自己从未分享过的小背景故事。哦，那个我为了让这一切在逻辑上说得通、对我来说显得真实而为自己脑补的故事是，安吉拉和参议员一直都知道菲利普根本不是他的骨肉。他们一直都知道。
I believe that. And they never discussed it, but I think they had very, very little intimacy in their marriage. And not to get too detailed, but I think there might have never been a true insemination. Yes. There you go. Right. It would be impossible for it to be his baby. Yes. There you go. Right. Like it would be impossible for it to be
我相信这一点。他们从没讨论过这件事，但我认为他们的婚姻生活中亲密关系极少。话别说得太细，但我认为他们可能从来没有过真正的受孕。对。就是这样。没错。这不可能是他的孩子。对。就是这样。没错。这不可能是
his baby. Yes and I think they both knew it and they were okay with it because they were gonna raise this child together and now that they're not the senator isn't invested. The other thing I thought of was just that based on everything we saw at the press conference, I think Angela wanted to get away from the senator very quickly. And sometimes you are going to take first place available, you know? And so this is what she could get her hands on quickly.
他的孩子。对，而且我认为他们俩都知道这一点，他们也接受了，因为他们原本打算一起抚养这个孩子，而现在他们不在一起了，参议员也就不投入了。我另一个想法是，根据我们在新闻发布会上看到的一切，我认为安吉拉当时非常想尽快离开参议员。有时候你会抓取能找到的第一个住处，你知道吗？所以这就是她当时能迅速弄到手的地方。
Yeah, she wanted out of there. And yeah. Well, I haven't shared my biggest thing yet about this scene. Oh, what is it? Well, I'm so delighted to share this because it this scene. Oh, what is it? Well, I'm so delighted to share this because it was such a warm, cozy memory for me.
是的，她想离开那个鬼地方。而且，是的。好吧，关于这个场景，我最重磅的事还没分享呢。哦，是什么？嗯，我很高兴能分享这个，因为这个场景。哦，是什么？嗯，我很高兴能分享这个，因为对我来说，这是一段非常温馨、舒适的记忆。
But when I was looking through my digital clutter, and I had remembered this, the minute I watched the episode, I was like, oh yeah. And I went to my digital clutter to look for it. The day we filmed this scene, my daughter, Isabelle, came to set for lunch. Now she was almost five years old at this time.
但是当我翻找我的数字杂物时，我想起了这件事，就在我看完这一集的那个瞬间，我心想：哦，对啊。然后我就去我的数字杂物里找它。我们拍摄这个场景的那天，我的女儿伊abelle来片场吃午饭。当时她快五岁了。
She knew everyone on set. You know, Jenna, they all doted on her. Our cast and crew were so lovely to our families. And I had a camera rehearsal for this scene. And Matt Stone was like, Isabel, do you want to pretend to be your mommy's baby in this scene? Oh, my gosh! Because Isabel knew we played make believe,
她认识片场的每一个人。你知道的，珍娜，他们所有人都很宠爱她。我们的演员和工作人员对我们的家人太好了。我当时在为这个场景进行摄像走位排练。马特·斯通就说：伊abelle，你想在这场戏里假装当你妈妈的宝贝吗？哦，天哪！因为伊abelle知道我们在玩过家家，
that's what mommy did for her job. And Isabel was very excited and she took it very seriously. She was like, yes. And then we did the rehearsal and I blocked it with Isabel, not with the actual baby. We wanted that baby to rest as much as it could, right? Yes.
那就是妈妈工作时做的事情。伊abelle非常兴奋，她对待这事极其认真。她回答说：好呀。然后我们排练了，我和伊abelle一起走位，而不是用真正的婴儿。我们希望那个婴儿能尽量多休息，对吧？是的。
And Matt filmed the blocking rehearsal and gave it to me and I have it. I'm gonna put it in stories, but it just made me so happy to see it and just have this memory. I'm gonna show it to you. There's no audio, lady, because it was just camera rehearsal.
马特把走位排练拍了下来，并传给了我，我还留着呢。我打算把它发到动态里，但看到它并拥有这段回忆让我感到非常开心。我要把它放给你看。没有声音，女士，因为那只是摄像走位。
Right. But here, you gotta see it. Oh my goodness, she's doing such a good job. She just has her head on your shoulder. She's pretending to be my baby. Aw, and you even put her in the crib. Uh-huh. And she pretends to have her little stuffed animal.
没错。但你看，你得看看这个。哦天哪，她做得太棒了。她的头就靠在你的肩膀上。她在假装当我的宝贝。啊，你甚至把她放进了婴儿床。嗯哼。她还假装拿着她的小毛绒玩具。
Isn't that so cute? So sweet. How fun that so cute? So sweet. How fun that Isabel has that too. I know. I know. That's so sweet. So anyway, I was texting with Matt Stone about it yesterday, and he totally remembered filming it as well.
是不是超级可爱？太甜了。伊abelle也有这样的回忆，多有趣啊。我懂。我懂。太温馨了。总之，我昨天还和马特·斯通发短信聊起这事，他也完全记得当时拍过这个。
And I was so thankful that I had it. Well, lady, we had a fan question from Erin H. in Denton, Texas, who wanted all the details on how you did the scene with the baby and the cats in the crib. Oh, yeah. And Steve Burgess shared, and I'm sure you remember, interesting fact. The shot of baby Philip in the crib covered by cats is not a real baby, it's an animatronic baby. You can tell, I'm sorry, but they worked really.
我很庆幸自己把它保留了下来。对了，女士，我们收到了来自得克萨斯州丹顿市的埃伦·H的粉丝提问，她想知道你拍摄婴儿和婴儿床里的猫咪那场戏的所有细节。哦，是的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯透露了一个有趣的事实，我确信你还记得。婴儿菲利普躺在婴儿床里、身上盖满猫咪的那个镜头，其实不是一个真正的婴儿，而是一个电子仿真婴儿。你能看出来，对不起，但他们做得真的。
You can see the arms. You can see the arms moved in a very rigid motion and if you pause it and then replay it, it's like, dang, dang, dang, dang, dang. Yes, it's a little bit Chuck E. Cheese, right? Yes, it's Chuck E. Cheese meets that American sniper movie with that fake baby. But of course, of course they weren't going to have the cats on a real baby. Of course not.
你能看到胳膊。你能看到胳膊以一种非常生硬的动作在移动，如果你暂停然后重播，就会觉得：天哪，天哪，天哪，天哪，天哪。是的，有点像芝士查克餐厅的机械玩偶，对吧？是的，简直是“芝士查克餐厅”碰上了那部带有假婴儿的电影《美国狙击手》。但当然，他们绝不可能把猫放在一个真正的婴儿身上。当然不可能。
Well, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we're going to hear how Dwight is feeling about Angela right now. It's very sweet. It is. We want these two together. We're rooting for them. We are back and Dwight has a talking head. He says, you know, I offered myself to Angela
好吧，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来后，我们要听听德怀特现在对安吉拉有什么感觉。这非常甜蜜。确实。我们希望这两个人能在一起。我们在为他们加油。我们回来了，德怀特有一个单独采访。他说：你知道的，我曾向安吉拉表白过，
and she turned me down. And there is some flashback footage We're gonna see this again later in the episode. The documentary crew is really editing in some previous footage Yeah, this is happening now and then Dwight says, you know, but I'm with Esther now and she's younger She's sturdier and she's more comfortable with the scent of a manured field, which let's be honest, Angela was just indifferent. At best. At best. Yeah, at best and different. Now Clark is going to approach Aaron and Pete. They're making their paper airplanes and Aaron aggressively shoes him away. And she's going to explain that growing up in an orphanage,
但她拒绝了我。这里有一些闪回镜头，我们稍后在本集中还会再次看到。纪录片摄制组真的剪辑了一些以前的镜头进来。是的，这正在发生。然后德怀特说：你知道的，但我现在和埃丝特在一起，她更年轻，她更健壮，而且她对施过肥的田野的气味更加适应，说实话，安吉拉对此最多也就是无所谓。最多也就是。最多也就是。是的，最多也就是无所谓。现在克拉克要去找艾伦和皮特了。他们正在做纸飞机，艾伦气势汹汹地把赶他走了。她要解释说，在孤儿院度过的童年里，
she had to fight other kids for everything. And she's very, very competitive, but she's worried about Pete seeing this side of her. Yeah. I have a paper airplane fact. Oh, great. I have a deleted scene. Oh, well, National Paper Airplane Day.
她不得不为了每样东西和别的孩子争抢。她好胜心极强，但她又担心皮特看到她这一面。是的。我有一个关于纸飞机的冷知识。哦，太棒了。我有一个删减片段。哦，对了，全国纸飞机日。
Did you know there was one? There is. I don't doubt it. I feel like there's a hashtag national blank day insert, the theme for everything now. It is May 26th. Oh. So there truly is a day for everything.
你知道有这个节日吗？有的。我对此毫不怀疑。我觉得现在到处都有那种“全国某某日”，什么主题都有。那是5月26日。哦。所以真的什么节日都有。
And if you wanna throw a paper airplane, throw it on May 26th. Let's see. Oh, I wanna share this deleted scene, you guys. Let's see. Oh, I want to share this deleted scene, you guys. Let's hear it. Well, what would have come next after this Aaron talking head was a driving scene between Daryl and Andy. And I love a good driving scene.
如果你想扔纸飞机，就在5月26日那天扔吧。让我看看。哦，我想和大家分享这段删减片段。让我看看。哦，我想和大家分享这段删减片段，伙计们。让我们听听。好吧，在这个艾伦的单独采访之后，接下来本应是一场达里尔和安迪在车里的戏。我最喜欢精彩的车内戏了。
It's in the deleted scenes. And I want to share it with you. Basically, they're on the way to the commercial shoot and Andy is kinda doing some prep in the car. He's hairspraying his hair, he's looking in the mirror and anyway, it's really fun, you gotta hear it. Andy, you couldn't have done that before? I wanna look good.
它在删减片段里。我想跟你们分享一下。基本上，他们是在去拍商业广告的路上，安迪在车里做一些准备工作。他在喷发胶，照着镜子，总之，真的很有趣，你们得听听。安迪，你刚才不能弄好吗？我想看起来精神点。
Come on. Jeez. Oh, hey, if they interview you for the behind the scenes, talk about how much we laughed on set. My hands are really sweaty. I think it's because it's so hot. It's 50 degrees outside. When my hands sweat, I squeeze ice cubes. It makes them sweat less.
拜托。天哪。哦，对了，如果他们采访你关于幕后的事，就说我们在片场笑得有多开心。我的手真的出汗了。我想是因为太热了。外面才50华氏度。我手一出汗，就捏冰块。这样手出汗就会少一点。
Really? Can you go on an ice run when we get there? You do know I'm missing work for this. It's day two of a paper airplane contest. I think we're okay. Fair point. Amazing. And I want you to know, Craig Robinson is so funny, from the minute he gets in that car to all of his reactions at the laboratory.
真的吗？我们到那儿的时候你能去买点冰块吗？你得知道我是为了这事翘了班呢。这已经是纸飞机大赛的第二天了。我想我们没事的。有道理。太棒了。而且我想让你们知道，克雷格·罗宾逊太搞笑了，从他坐进那辆车里的那一刻起，到他在实验室里的各种反应。
But what cracked me up, Jen, on watching it is when he says, hey, if they ask you about what we're like on set, tell them how we're always laughing all the time, you know? And it was kind of funny because whenever we would do press junkets as a cast, one of the questions we got asked every single time was like, who's the prankster? Who's making everyone laugh on set?
但珍，我看着觉得最好笑的是，当他说：嘿，如果他们问你我们在片场是什么样的人，告诉他们我们总是笑个不停，你知道吗？这其实挺搞笑的，因为每当我们作为演员去参加记者圆桌采访时，每次必被问到的问题之一就是：谁是恶作剧大王？谁在片场把大家都逗笑？
It's true. I felt like this was like our writer's nod to like these same questions we would always get. Well, I don't want to tell everybody in Hollywood what to do, but if you want Craig Robinson to be really funny in your project, put him in a car. Because I think he really shines in all the driving scenes. Like when he's with Michael and Holly,
真的。我觉得这就好像是编剧在向我们总是会被问到的这些相同问题致敬。好吧，我不是想对好莱坞的所有人指手画脚，但如果你想让克雷格·罗宾逊在你的项目里表现得非常搞笑，就把他塞进一辆车里。因为我觉得他在所有的车内戏里都真的大放异彩。就像他和迈克尔、霍莉在一起时，
when he and I had our driving scene, his show, Killing It, they spend a lot of time in a car. And he is very funny in a car, everybody. Yeah. I don't know what it is. Well, Daryl and Andy are going to arrive to this project, and Carla is there. Carla seems a little interested in Daryl.
当我和他有车内戏时，他的剧《戴罪立功》里，他们花了很多时间在车里。他在车里真的非常搞笑，各位。是的。我也不知道为什么。好吧，达里尔和安迪到达了这个拍摄项目现场，卡拉也在那里。卡拉似乎对达里尔有点兴趣。
She's like, hey, are you in this paper documentary as well? Do you need an agent? And Andy's like, no, no, no, no. No. He doesn't act. And then Daryl has this throwaway line. He says, well, I was in the whiz in high school. That was not in the script.
她说：嘿，你也是这纸业纪录片里的人吗？你需要经纪人吗？安迪却说：不不不不不。不。他不演戏。然后达里尔随口说了一句台词。他说：嗯，我高中时演过《新绿野仙踪》。那根本不在剧本里。
I don't know if they just found that on the day. Oh, that's so fun. Well, I loved this next scene. Carla is gonna show Andy that he's got a chair because all her actors get chairs. I thought this was very funny since not a single one of us ever had a chair on the office. We did not have. Never got a chair.
我不知道他们是不是当场现挂的。哦，太有趣了。好吧，我喜欢接下来的这场戏。卡拉要向安迪展示他有一把椅子，因为她所有的演员都有椅子。我觉得这非常搞笑，因为我们在《办公室》里从头到尾没有一个人拥有过椅子。我们根本没有。从来没有过椅子。
A director's chair. No. But it is really funny. I loved it when she said, all my actors sit. Yes, exactly. Very proudly. I want you to know Halstead said that they did shoot in an actual laboratory.
导演椅。没有。但这真的很好笑。我最喜欢她说“我所有的演员都要坐着”那句了。是的，没错。非常骄傲。我想让你们知道，霍尔斯特德说过他们确实是在一个真正的实验室里拍摄的。
This is an actual laboratory. We got a fan question about it. Sarah M. in Victoria, Canada said, I'm a PhD student specializing in immunology and I spend a significant amount of time in a lab. And when I see lab scenes in TV shows or movies, they tend to look far from realistic, incredibly pristine and perfectly organized.
这是一个真正的实验室。我们收到了一个关于它的粉丝提问。来自加拿大维多利亚的萨拉·M说：我是一名专攻免疫学的博士生，花在实验室的时间相当多。每当我在电视剧或电影里看到实验室场景时，它们往往看起来很不真实，极其一尘不染且完美井然有序。
However, in this particular episode, I was genuinely impressed as it was evident to me that the lab where Andy shot the laboratory safety video looked like a real working laboratory. Well, Sarah, we did shoot in a real lab. Steve Burgess said that there were no special safety issues at the lab, but there were some areas that were off limits. It wasn't because anything like top secret was happening, but they just didn't want us to mess their things up because they were a real lab. Steve said that we had our normal safety meetings, but we added one thing to the lab, which were some fakey bubbling beakers in the background. So fakey beakers.
然而，在这集里，我真的印象深刻，因为对我来说很明显，安迪拍摄实验室安全视频的那个实验室看起来就像一个真实运作的实验室。好吧，萨拉，我们确实是在一个真正的实验室拍摄的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，实验室里没有任何特殊的安全问题，但有一些区域是禁止进入的。这倒不是因为有什么绝密事件在发生，而是他们只是不想让我们把他们的东西弄乱，因为那是个真正的实验室。史蒂夫说，我们召开了常规的安全会议，但我们在实验室里加了一样东西，那就是背景里一些假冒的冒泡烧杯。所以就是假烧杯。
Fakey beakers, real lab. That's right. Oh, I also want to give a guest star shout out to Kate Comer. She's the woman who comes up to take Andy's photo. Yes, it's very funny. Andy thinks, oh, it's starting, the paparazzi. And she's like, we just need a picture of your hair in case we burn it. Yes.
假烧杯，真实验室。没错。哦，我还想对客串演员凯特·科默表示感谢。她就是那个走过来给安迪拍照的女人。是的，太搞笑了。安迪以为，哦，开始了，狗仔队来咯。结果她说：我们只是需要拍一张你头发的照片，以防把它烧焦。是的。
This is something we had to do every day on the office several times a day. They're called continuity photos. Everyone takes them. Hair and makeup take them. Wardrobe takes them. Props makeup take them, wardrobe takes them, props take them, and you have to pose. And sometimes you have to give a profile, the back of your head, your hands.
这是我们在《办公室》里每天都要做的事，一天要做好几次。这叫连戏照片。每个人都要拍。发型和化妆要拍。服装要拍。道具化妆要拍，服装要拍，道具要拍，而且你还得摆好姿势。有时你还得拍侧面照、脑后照、手部特写。
Oh, when Kim Ferry would do the complicated braids, she would have to take all these photos of the back of my head. Mm-hmm. So that the braids matched every day. And they would print these out, and then they would put them in these elaborate binders. Mm-hmm.
哦，当金·费里做那些复杂的辫子时，她不得不给我脑后拍一堆照片。嗯哼。这样每天的辫子都能连上。然后他们把这些照片打印出来，放进制作精美的文件夹里。嗯哼。
And every once in a while, oh, talk about, you know how Toby's so excited to get out a binder? Talk about how excited hair and makeup was when we would have to go back to a previous episode and reshoot something or create extra footage. They had the binder with the hair and the makeup. Yes, she would go in, she'd be like, shoot something or create extra footage. They had the binder with the hair and the makeup. Yes, she would go in, she would be like, I got it.
偶尔，哦，说到这个，你知道托比拿到一个文件夹时有多兴奋吗？说说发型和化妆部门在我们要回到以前的某集去重拍某些镜头或补拍额外镜头时有多兴奋吧。他们有存着发型和化妆照片的文件夹。是的，她会走过去，说：拍点东西或者创作一些额外的素材。他们有存着发型和化妆照片的文件夹。是的，她会走过去，说道：我找到了。
You want to recreate season five, episode 13, scene 4A? And she'd flip to the page and there all of our hair would be. And she would be like, Angela, you were half up, half down. Jenna, you were in a ponytail. Lady, part of my digital clutter and photos from this episode, I took a lot of our crew. You did? Yeah, so I have hair and makeup backstage, you know,
你想重现第五季第十三集第四A场吗？然后她翻到那一页，上面就有我们所有人的发型记录。她会说：安吉拉，你当时是半扎发。珍娜，你扎的是马尾辫。女士，作为我数字杂物和这集照片的一部分，我拍了很多我们的工作人员。你拍了？嗯哼，所以我拍了后台的发型和化妆师，你知道的，
at their tables, and I have our crew all in the warehouse as we were figuring out the paper airplane scenes. I'll put all of them in stories. It just, I just love seeing everyone. Well, speaking of the warehouse, the competition is underway and it's gonna start with Kevin versus Angela. Yeah, Kevin has a pretty fancy looking plane
在他们的桌子旁，我还拍了我们在琢磨纸飞机场景时仓库里的所有工作人员。我把这些全发到动态里。我只是，我只是喜欢看到每个人。好吧，说到仓库，比赛正在进行中，将从凯文对阵安吉拉开始。是的，凯文拿了一个看起来挺别致的飞机，
and Dwight questions it. He's looking out for Angela. He's like, you made that paper airplane and Brian's performance is so great right here. Like he literally, it here like he literally it's like he manifests a sweat Kevin's like um well sort of and then we find out that Kevin bought it online yeah so they call for a refold he has to refold and you're gonna see him at like a table and he's been folding planes forever
而德怀特对此产生了质疑。他在为安吉拉留意着。他说：你真的是自己做那个纸飞机的吗？布赖恩在这里的表演太棒了。就像他字面意思一样，在这里就像他字面意思一样，就像他凭空逼出了汗。凯文说：嗯，算是吧。然后我们发现凯文那是网上买的。所以他们要求重新折叠，他必须重新折叠。然后你会看到他在一张桌子旁，他一直在那儿折飞机，
trying to make a plane. Guess what? Facts come in your way. Paper airplane facts inspired by this moment. Do you know what the most paper airplanes made in one hour is? In one hour, someone made 12,026 paper airplanes, which is about one every 3.3 seconds.
试图做出一个飞机来。你猜怎么着？硬核事实来袭。由这一刻激发的纸飞机冷知识。你知道在一小时内折出的纸飞机最多是多少架吗？在一小时内，有人折了12,026架纸飞机，大约每3.3秒一架。
Do you think the person that did that has like little special like bandages on their fingers like how my mom has that little rubber thing you put on your finger when you're sewing? You must. Because the paper cuts, I like are all over the place. Yeah. Also, I mean, what is the quality of a paper airplane that you made in 3.3 seconds? I don't know. There's no quality control here. It's just volume. I also found out that the fastest time to fold and then throw a paper airplane, so in this case you actually had to make like a flyable device, so
你觉得那个做这事的人手指上有没有那种小小的专用创可贴？就像我妈缝纫时套在手指上的那个小橡胶套一样？肯定有。因为纸划伤，我感觉到处都是。而且，话说回来，你花3.3秒钟折出来的纸飞机能有什么质量？我不知道。这里根本没有什么质量控制。只有数量。我还发现，最快折好并扔出纸飞机（在这种情况下，你实际上必须制作一个能飞的装置，即
fold and throw the fastest time is 7.03 seconds. 7 seconds? Yeah, 7.03. You would fold and then throw it and it flew. That is the fastest time. That's crazy. And so that's why I'm like, okay, if the most paper airplanes made in one hour was like a little over 12,000, they're having to fold like these paper airplanes
折好并扔出去）的最快时间是7.03秒。7秒？是的，7.03秒。你把它折好然后扔出去，它飞了。那是这方面的最快纪录。太疯狂了。所以这就是为什么我在想，好吧，如果一小时内制作最多的纸飞机是一万两千多架的话，他们肯定得在3.3秒内折好这些纸飞机。但为了折出一个能飞得最快的纸飞机并把它扔出去需要七秒钟。我在想，那一万两千架飞机里，有很多根本就不具备飞行能力。你知道我的意思吗？你觉得呢？这和凯文的那堆东西很像，看起来就像一堆随手乱折的纸，也许只有20%看起来像飞机。我不知道。是的。他在挣扎。我问过沃伦和霍尔斯特德，有没有什么他们希望能够剪进这一集的删减片段。霍尔斯特德分享了一段他们写的单独采访。它在拍摄剧本里。
in 3.3 seconds. But in order to fold and throw one that flies the fastest is seven seconds. I'm thinking a lot of those 12,000 airplanes were not flight worthy. You know what I'm saying? You think? Similar to Kevin's pile, which looks like a bunch of just randomly folded paper and maybe 20% look like airplanes. I don't know. Yeah. He's struggling. I asked Warren and Halstead if there were any deleted scenes that they wish could have made it in this episode. And Halstead shared a talking head that they wrote. It's in the shooting draft.
而且真的非常搞笑。我来读一下。那是德怀特，他刚刚戳穿了凯文，指出那个纸飞机根本不是凯文自己做的。这里原本有一个单独采访。德怀特说：他绝对不可能造出那个飞机。我曾经眼睁睁看着他花了20分钟试图把一封信塞进信封里。你们没听错。你们没听错。
And it is really funny. I'm going to read it. It's Dwight, and he's just called Kevin out that Kevin did not make that paper airplane. And here was a talking head. Dwight says, there is no way he built that plane. I once watched him spend 20 minutes trying to put an envelope into a letter. You heard me. You heard me.
总之，那个也把我逗笑了。那段挺棒的。好吧，我们应该提到的一点是，安吉拉注意到了德怀特在这里的表现。是的。她有一个单独采访。确实如此。她对着镜头说：德怀特是在为我加油吗？嗯。我之前没注意到呢。嗯哼。是的。她对此感到非常高兴。她当然很高兴。回到办公区，吉姆给帕姆拿了一杯茶，她很感激。确实如此。他解释说，其实他本来就要去厨房，因为他自己也想喝杯茶。然后帕姆说出了实情，那就是她其实在三月份就已经改喝咖啡了，但她依然很感激这个举动。是的。所以这里原本有一个被剪掉的单独采访。嗯哼。吉姆本打算说
Anyway, that cracked me up too. That was pretty great. Well, something we should mention is that Angela has taken notice of Dwight's behavior here. Yeah. She has a talking head. She does. She says to camera, was Dwight rooting for me? Hmm. I hadn't noticed. Mm hmm. Yeah. She's very delighted by this. She sure is. Back in the bullpen, Jim has brought Pam a cup of tea, which she appreciates. She does. He shares that the truth is he was going in the kitchen anyway because he felt like a cup of tea for himself. And then Pam shares her truth, which is she actually switched to coffee back in March, but she still appreciates the gesture. Yeah. So there was a talking head here that they cut. Mm-hmm. Jim was gonna say
类似这样的话：哇，她改喝咖啡了。然后他会停顿一下，说点类似的话：
something like, wow, she switched to coffee. And then he was gonna pause and say something like, Wow, she switched to coffee. And then he was going to pause and say something like, but she still likes mixed berries, right? Like he was going to reference the mixed berries yogurt. I know. You know, when I saw this scene, it really hit me. I was like, this is significant.
哇，她改喝咖啡了。然后他会停顿一下，说点类似的话：但她还是喜欢混合浆果口味的，对吧？就像他会提到混合浆果酸奶一样。我知道。你知道的，当我看到这个场景时，我真的触动很深。我心想：这意义重大。
You don't know her morning drink. Like you are so disconnected from one another that you don't know her morning drink. Like, you are so disconnected from one another that you don't know this big piece of information that's a part of her every day. You know what I mean? This is the everyday intimacy. And it is missing from Jim and Pam's life. And I would say, I think it's the very small,
你竟然不知道她早晨喝什么饮料。你们俩之间竟然疏离到了这种地步，连对方早晨喝什么饮料都不知道。你们竟然疏离到了这种地步，连这个作为她日常生活一部分的重要信息都不知道。你知道我的意思吗？这就是日常生活的亲密感。而它在吉姆和帕姆的生活中缺失了。我想说，这正是生活中那些非常微小的、
little things in life. That's how you know someone truly. It's very easy to know the big things, you know? But it's the very small, intimate things that separate a relationship. Yes, exactly. Well, that's just good writing, right? I know.
细小的事情。通过这些，你才能真正了解一个人。了解那些大事很容易，你知道吗？但正是那些非常微小、亲密的细节，才拉开了人与人之间的距离。是的，完全正确。好吧，这就是好剧本的魅力，对吧？我知道。
It's just really good writing. Really, really good writing. Well, speaking of really good writing that didn't make it in, back at the laboratory, there was a scene that would have gone here. And Andy, because it's an industrial shoot, had to do his own hair and makeup, Jenna. What does Andy know about hair and makeup?
这真的是绝佳的剧本。真的是非常棒的剧本。好吧，说到那些没能播出的绝佳剧本，回到实验室，这里原本有一场戏。安迪因为这是一场工业拍摄，不得不自己弄发型和化妆，珍娜。安迪对发型和化妆懂什么？
He knows the world of the theater. Oh, boy. He does full stage makeup. He penciled in his eyebrows. He has on white eyeshadow. He has on that orange kind of base, you know, like that heavy foundation with bright red like blushed cheeks. Well they need to see you from the back row, from the balcony. And you have those harsh lights on you on the theater, you know? Oh my gosh, he walks into the laboratory in his lab coat with this stage makeup.
他懂戏剧的世界啊。哦，天哪。他画了全套的舞台妆。他用铅笔画了眉毛。他涂了白色的眼影。他涂了那种橘色的底妆，你知道的，就像那种厚重的粉底配上鲜红的腮红。好吧，因为你得让最后一排、楼上的观众都看到你。而且你在戏剧里要面对那些刺眼的灯光，你知道的！哦，天哪，他穿着实验室白大褂走进实验室，脸上化着这种舞台妆。
Everyone's reactions are hilarious, and I wanted you to hear the clip. It's in deleted scenes. I cannot wait. Ta-da! Meet the lab assistant. What's with the clown face? It's professional stage makeup. Keeps from washing out under the harsh lights. I learned it when I was naked poo in the micado. Andrew Bedard?
所有人的反应都太搞笑了，我想让你们听听这段音频。它在删减片段里。我等不及了。哒哒！见见实验室助理。你这小丑脸是怎么回事？这是专业的舞台妆。能防止在刺眼的灯光下被洗白。我是在《米卡多》里演裸体便便时学到的。安德鲁·贝达德？
What's on your face? A little of the old grease paint, governor. Lashes sold separately. Um, I'm gonna need him to take this off immediately, okay? Question, is it too dark? Because this is Trinidad. I also have Brazilian Matador or Man of Athens. How about no makeup at all? No makeup.
你脸怎么回事？一点老式的油彩，长官。睫毛另售。嗯，我需要他立刻把这个卸掉，好吗？请问，是不是太浓了？因为这是特立尼达风格。我还有巴西斗士或雅典人风格。要不干脆不化装得了？不化妆。
No makeup? Great, I can do that. But, question, new to the area, is there a makeup remover store nearby? Uh, you'll just use soap. Wow. Yeah. I love it. Halstead said when Ed said, Man of Athens, it made everyone crack up. Well, I have a guest star shout out. Ooh, I bet I know who it is. Yes, I know you do. It's the producer on set. He was played by an old improv friend
不化妆？太好了，我可以做到。不过，请问，刚来这附近，附近有卖卸妆用品的店吗？呃，你直接用肥皂洗就行了。哇。是的。太棒了。霍尔斯特德说，当埃德说出“雅典人风格”时，把大家都逗笑了。好吧，我要对一位客串演员表示感谢。哦，我敢打赌我知道是谁。是的，我知道你知道。他是片场的制片人。他由我和沃伦的一位老即兴喜剧朋友
of mine and Warren's, Pete Holney. Pete has been in so many movies and television shows. You can catch him in Criminal Minds right now. He was in Jury Duty by our very own Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky. He's in Monsters Season Two on Netflix. If you're a fan of the movie Elf, Pete and his real twin brother, Patrick Holney,
皮特·霍尼饰演。皮特参演过无数电影和电视剧。你现在可以在《犯罪心理》里看到他。他还参演了由我们自己的李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基制作的《陪审团义务》。他还在网飞的《怪物》第二季里出演。如果你是电影《精灵总动员》的粉丝，皮特和他的双胞胎兄弟帕特里克·霍尼，
are the twin Elfs in the movie. And Warren shared with me that it was really a really fun shoot day for him because Pete was there and they'd known each other for so long, and that he was always pitching Pete for roles in The Office. And so he was so glad it finally worked out and I reached out to Pete and Lady he has a really sweet story about Allison Jones and I thought you should hear it. Okay. An interesting thing is like casting
就是电影里的那对双胞胎精灵。沃伦告诉我，对他来说这真的是非常开心的一天拍摄，因为皮特也在，他们认识很久了，而且沃伦一直都在向剧组推荐皮特出演《办公室》的角色。所以他很高兴事情最终成了真，我联系了皮特，女士，他有一个关于艾莉森·琼斯的非常温馨的故事，我觉得你应该听听。好的。有趣的是，选角
directors remember actors if they're good and when you audition for things and you don't get the part the amazing amazing thing is that the casting director's mind has to remember actors, and when things come up, they remember them. So, Alison Jones, who is the casting director of the show, remembered me from, I don't know, auditioning the first time. But the weird thing was is that she did something wonderful to me once. I was at The Grove, which is like a big shopping mall
导演如果觉得演员不错是会记住他们的，当你去面试各种角色却没有被录用时，神奇至极的是，选角导演的脑海里必须记住这些演员，当有合适的机会出现时，他们就会想起来。所以，该剧的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯，就从我不知道什么时候第一次面试开始，就记住我了。但奇怪的是，她曾经对我做过一件极其美妙的事。当时我在“The Grove”，那是一个大型购物中心，
here in Los Angeles in Farmer's Market. And I was going up an escalator and I just heard this voice yelling, Peter, Peter, Peter Holney. And I was like, who the hell is screaming my name? And all these people are like looking around, seeing who the hell this Peter Holney is. And I look down, and as the escalator's going up, I'm going down, and I see this woman waving frantically, and I looked at her like, who are you?
就在洛杉矶的农夫市场这里。我当时正坐着自动扶梯往上走，突然听到一个声音在喊：彼得，彼得，彼得·霍尼。我当时想：到底是谁在鬼喊鬼叫我的名字？周围所有的人都在东张西望，看看到底谁是这个彼得·霍尼。我往下看去，随着我坐的扶梯往上、她坐的扶梯往下，我看到一个女人在疯狂地挥手，我看着她，心想：你谁啊？
I can't even put, my brain couldn't process it. And she goes, it's me, Alison Jones from casting. And then all of a sudden, as she was going up, I was going down, she just kind of disappeared. And I was just dumbstruck. I didn't know what to do because I've never been cast by her yet, and I was just amazed that she remembered me.
我简直无法理解，我的大脑根本处理不了这个信息。然后她喊道：是我，选角导演艾莉森·琼斯。然后突然间，随着她往上走、我往下走，她就这样消失在视线里了。我当时惊呆了。我不知道该怎么办，因为我还没被她选中过，我只是惊叹于她竟然还记得我。
And I was like, oh my God, Alison Jones knows my name, knows my face, and said my last name correctly. And I just thought that was just a wonderful... I mean, all day long, I was walking around with my head up high going, I mean, all day long, I was walking around with my head up high going, all right, all right, Hollywood, you guys think I'm something special.
当时我就想：哦，天哪，艾莉森·琼斯知道我的名字，认得我的脸，而且还把我的姓氏念得完全正确。我当时觉得那简直太美妙了……我是说，那一整天，我都高昂着头在街上走来走去，心想：好吧，好吧，好莱坞，你们这群人觉得我可不是等闲之辈。
Oh, I love Alison. I do too. Can't you just see her yelling, hey? I mean, she is just a wonderful person. And I just love that story and wanted to share that side of her with everyone that we know. And I just love that story and wanted to share that side of her with everyone that we know. Yes, I love that.
哦，我太喜欢艾莉森了。我也是。你难道想象不出她大喊“嘿”的样子吗？我的意思是，她真的是个极其美好的人。我太喜欢这个故事了，也想把她那一面分享给我们认识的每一个人。我太喜欢这个故事了，也想把她那一面分享给我们认识的每一个人。是的，我太喜欢了。
And here's Pete's story about how this role came to be for him. I was flying home to Chicago for Christmas with my kids and my lovely wife. And we just landed. And out of nowhere, I got a call from my agent. And they said, hey, you just booked the office. And I kind of laughed.
这里是皮特关于他是如何得到这个角色的故事。我当时正带着我的孩子们和我可爱的妻子飞回芝加哥过圣诞节。我们刚落地。突然间，我接到了经纪人的电话。他们说：嘿，你刚接下了《办公室》的通告。我当时笑了一下。
I go, ha, I'm in Chicago. You know that. I booked out. Alison Jones just called up and said, she wants to book you. Well, I'm in Chicago. We just landed. And I'm building a snowman with my daughter, Sophia, because they've never seen snow before, because they live in LA.
我说：哈，我在芝加哥呢。你们知道的。我已经请假离组了。艾莉森·琼斯刚打电话来说，她想让你来演。好吧，我在芝加哥。我们刚落地。我正在和我的女儿索菲亚一起堆雪人，因为他们住在洛杉矶，从来没见过雪。
Anyways, so they were like you need to either do this or just decline it so I thought for a minute as I put like the carrot in to the snowman's face well I'm not gonna let this opportunity pass me by I guess my Christmas vacation is gonna be put on hold because I'm flying back to be on the office. That day, I think I booked a flight and got there the next morning. And it was just amazing because those kinds of things never happen.
总之，他们当时说你需要要么接下这个工作，要么就拒绝它。我一边把胡萝卜插进雪人的脸里，一边思考了一会儿：好吧，我可不能让这个机会从我指尖溜走。看来我的圣诞假期得暂时搁置了，因为我要飞回去参演《办公室》。那天，我想我订了张机票，第二天早上就赶到了。这简直太神奇了，因为这种事通常绝不会发生。
You don't just usually book a job without even auditioning for it. But Alison Jones just remembered me and gave me the part. Well that is really special when you're just like, hey, you got the role. You're like, what? Yeah, you're like a role I didn't even know was happening. It existed, yeah. And Warren told me he was really happy because when you have an episode that is your episode that you wrote, you are in direct communication with the director. And that doesn't normally happen
你通常不会在甚至都没试镜的情况下就直接接到一份工作。但艾莉森·琼斯就是记住了我，并把这个角色给了我。嗯，当你听到“嘿，你拿到角色了”时，这种感觉真的很特别。你会想：什么？对啊，你会觉得：这是一个我甚至都不知道它存在的角色。它确实存在，是的。沃伦告诉我他当时真的很高兴，因为当你遇到一集是由你亲自执笔的剧集时，你可以与导演直接沟通。通常情况下，
when it's not your episode, you don't really go to the director, right? You don't pitch anything. But because it was his episode, he was able to talk directly to Jesse and say, we've got this great guy and really push that through for Pete. Well, I'll tell you what, as an actor,
如果不是你写的剧集，你是不会这样的，你不会去找导演，对吧？你不会去推销任何创意。但因为那是他写的剧集，他可以直接和杰西对话，说：我们有这么个绝佳的演员，并且极力为皮特争取到了这个角色。好吧，我告诉你，作为一名演员，
if you want to get a job, just leave town. Well, that's true. Any time. Yes, if as soon as your friend tells you they're getting married out of town, you're going to book a job. It happened with me and you, Angela. Yeah. When you and Josh set your wedding date, I was like, I'm so excited. I'm going to be there the whole week with you as you get ready. Booked a movie with Ben Stiller. Yep. Was in Montreal, flew in the morning of your wedding. I did tell them I have to be at this wedding. I was so thankful and I was like, Oh my God, you're going to be so tired. But you got there. But it's true. It's true. I mean, you and I had some plans this next week,
如果你想找工作，只要离开镇子就行。嗯，这倒是真的。随时都可以。是的，只要你朋友一告诉你他们要去外地结婚，你就会接到工作。我和你就是这样的，安琪拉。是的。当你和乔什定下婚礼日期时，我就想，我太兴奋了。我要和你在一起整整一周，陪你做准备。结果接了一部本·斯蒂勒的电影。对。当时在蒙特利尔，在你婚礼那天早晨飞了回来。我确实告诉他们我必须参加这个婚礼。我非常感激，我想，天哪，你肯定累坏了。但你还是赶到了。不过这是真的。真的。我是说，你和我原本计划好下周要见面的，
and I booked a job. You booked a job, and here we are. Here we are on a Saturday morning with Cassie. Oh my gosh. Thank you, ladies. It's how it goes. Leave town, and you'll book a job. Yep.
结果我接了个工作。你接了工作，然后我们就这样了。我们就这样在星期六的早晨和卡西在一起了。哦，天哪。谢谢你们，女士们。事情就是这样。离开小镇，你就会接到工作。对。
Well, let's see. They're going to start rolling on Andy. And he's making a number of strange choices. Yes, first he's gonna smile really big the whole time. Yep. And the producer's like, what are you doing? Why are you smiling? And then the director's like,
好吧，我们来看看。他们要在安迪身上开拍了。而他做出了一系列奇怪的选择。是的，首先他会全程笑得非常灿烂。对。然后制片人就问，你在干什么？你笑什么？然后导演就说，
just do it like you're doing like a news anchor, you know, like you're telling your news. You're delivering the news, say it straight. Oh my gosh, lady. And that's when we get Ed Helms doing Tom Brokaw. Finally! Amazing, it makes it on the show what he's been doing behind the scenes
就像你做新闻主播那样做，你知道的，就像你在播新闻一样。你在播报新闻，语气要正经点。哦，天哪，女士。然后我们就看到埃德·赫尔姆斯模仿汤姆·布罗考。终于！太棒了，他这些年来在幕后
for us all these years. Yes, this bit that we all loved. And lady, I had to play it. We have to hear it. Let's hear it. This video is to demonstrate the HPRDC chemical handling protocols. This is Tom Brokaw. It's a newscaster, come on.
为我们做的事终于在这个节目里播出了。是的，这个我们都很喜欢的桥段。天哪，我得把它放出来。我们必须听听。我们听听吧。本视频旨在演示HPRDC化学品处理规程。这是汤姆·布罗考。是个新闻主播，得了吧。
Who is it? Tom Brokaw. And Daryl's look behind. I know. He's like, oh man. I wanted to mention that the other gentleman in these scenes playing the director is John Phillips. He recently co-wrote the film, No Hard Feelings,
是谁？汤姆·布罗考。还有达里尔在后面的表情。我知道。他就像是在说，天哪。我得提一下，这些场景里扮演导演的另一位绅士是约翰·菲利普斯。他最近联合编剧了电影《无损尊严》，
which was directed by our very own Jean Stupnitsky. It was also produced by my manager, Naomi Odenkirk, and Jennifer Lawrence was nominated for a Golden Globe for her performance in this movie in 2024. It also won the People's Choice Award for Comedy Movie of the Year. Nice. I know.
该片由我们亲爱的吉恩·斯图普尼茨基执导。它还由我的经纪人娜奥米·奥登科克制作，詹妮弗·劳伦斯凭借该片在2024年获得金球奖最佳女主角提名。它还荣获了人民选择奖的年度喜剧电影。太棒了。我知道。
And also, finally for this scene, I have to read this fan catch from Tom F. in Wolverhampton, UK. Because Tom said, I have been waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting to submit this from the first episodes of your wonderful podcast. Tom spotted a continuity thing, and Tom said, I haven't spotted a single other thing,
还有，这一幕的最后，我必须宣读这份来自英国伍尔弗汉普顿的汤姆·F.的粉丝留言。因为汤姆说，我等了又等、等了又等、等了又等，从你们这个精彩播客的第一集就开始等，就为了提交这个发现。汤姆发现了一个连贯性问题，汤姆说，我没发现任何其他问题，
unlike many of your other contributors. So I'm really hoping that I'm the person who saw this one. Oh my gosh, what is it? Here's what he saw. Tom says, when being filmed, Andy repeatedly calls the company HPRDC, but the company badge that he's wearing says HRPDC. So Andy is getting the letters wrong when he speaks. Tom said, is this Ed misreading the script, or did the props and graphics
不像你们的其他许多投稿人。所以我真的很希望我是发现这个细节的人。哦，天哪，是什么？这就是他发现的。汤姆说，在拍摄时，安迪多次把公司名称称为HPRDC，但他戴的公司胸卡上写的是HRPDC。所以安迪在说话时字母说错了。汤姆说，这是埃德看错了剧本，还是道具和图形
department create the wrong label, or was it scripted that he say it wrong? Well that is a fantastic question. Well Tom, I'm going to the shooting draft and here is how it read in the shooting draft. Andy was supposed to say, this video is to demonstrate the HPRDC chemical handling protocol. Okay, so I don't know why his badge says HRPDC. Which one is correct? We don't know. Did we get to the bottom of it or did we mom detective it? I think we mom detective to this one. We confirmed that Ed said his line correctly. Yes.
部门制作了错误的标签，还是剧本里就要求他念错？这真是一个绝妙的问题。好吧，汤姆，我去看了一下拍摄剧本，拍摄剧本上的内容是这样的。安迪本该说，本视频旨在演示HPRDC化学品处理规程。好吧，所以我不知道为什么他的胸卡上写的是HRPDC。哪个才是正确的？我们不知道。我们弄清楚了真相，还是发挥了妈妈侦探的本领？我想我们在这件事上发挥了妈妈侦探的本领。我们确认了埃德台词念得没错。是的。
And we know that the badge doesn't match the line, but we don't know if it was a mistake or we'll never know. We'll never know. We tried, Tom. Back in the warehouse, next up is Clark versus Aaron. Aaron's plane flies so far, she's really pumped. And then she goes at Clark really hard, calling him piggy, oinking in his face.
而且我们知道胸卡和台词不匹配，但我们不知道这是一个失误，还是我们永远也不会知道。我们永远也不会知道。我们努力过了，汤姆。回到仓库里，接下来是克拉克对阵艾伦。艾伦的飞机飞得好远，她斗志昂扬。然后她对克拉克发起猛烈攻击，叫他小猪，在他脸上学猪叫。
Even Pete is like, Aaron, you need to relax. And Clark is like, we still gotta work together, so. Yeah. You know what? There was even more in deleted scenes. Erin would have yelled off camera, let's get this cotton picking show on the road, mother. Oh boy.
连皮特都觉得，艾伦，你需要放松点。而克拉克则表示，我们还得一起工作呢，所以。是的。你知道吗？被删减的片段里还有更多内容。艾伦本会在镜头外大喊，把这场该死的好戏开演吧，妈妈。哦，天哪。
Yeah, scripted shot. Wow. Yeah. Wow. They were really showing Erin's competitive side and they were also clocking the fact that Pete was like, what is going on? Well, Phyllis and Dwight are up next. Angela heckles Phyllis. Dwight wins.
是的，剧本里的镜头。哇。真的。哇。他们确实展现了艾伦好胜的一面，他们还注意到皮特当时的反应是，这到底是怎么回事。好吧，接下来是菲利斯和德怀特。安琪拉对菲利斯进行嘘声干扰。德怀特获胜。
Angela's very happy. But ooh, plot twist, Esther has arrived. Yeah, Esther has arrived, full of energy and she runs over to Dwight, gives him a big victory kiss. Angela's not happy about that. She says she plucked the chickens extra fast so she could come support him. We got a lot of fan questions Angela
安琪拉非常高兴。但是哦，剧情大反转，埃斯特来了。是的，埃斯特来了，充满活力，她跑向德怀特，给了他一个巨大的胜利之吻。安琪拉对此很不高兴。她说她拔鸡毛格外快，所以才能赶来支持他。安琪拉，我们收到了很多粉丝的问题
about the paper airplanes. We're gonna get into a lot of scenes now of the paper airplane throwing. People wanted to know, were the paper airplanes photoshopped? And Jenny M from Katy, Texas said, did Phil Shea have to make all those paper airplanes? Were they CGI? Did we throw them ourselves?
关于纸飞机。接下来我们将看到很多扔纸飞机的场景。人们想知道，纸飞机是P出来的吗？来自德克萨斯州凯蒂镇的珍妮·M说，菲尔·谢伊必须制作所有那些纸飞机吗？它们是CGI制作的吗？是我们自己扔的吗？
How was this done? Well, I can tell you, I remembered immediately when I rewatched this, I even called you about it, Jenna. I was like, remember the professional paper airplane fellas they brought in? These guys came and made these airplanes. They were works of art, really. And I'm going to point out later the moment where mine actually went far because my real
这是怎么做到的？嗯，我可以告诉你，当我重看这一段时，我立刻就想起来了，珍妮，我甚至还为了这事给你打过电话。我说，还记得他们请来的专业纸飞机专家吗？这些人来做这些飞机。它们真的是艺术品。我等一下要指出我飞得远的那一刻，因为我当时真实的
reaction is very honest. But yeah, I remember these guys, they were set up in the warehouse. They had folded all these planes. They did show us kind of this arm motion to make. You can see the people that win kind of have a similar arm motion, you know? Yep.
反应非常诚实。不过是的，我记得这些人，他们在仓库里搭了摊位。他们折好了所有这些飞机。他们确实给我们示范了一种摆臂动作。你可以看到获胜的人都有着类似的摆臂动作，对吧？ yep.
Dwight and Angela and Erin, we kind of throw them the same way. So I know there were real paper airplanes, but I also know they had to zhuzh it a little in editing. Yeah, I mean, the answer is they're not CGI airplanes. They're all real. And you know, the cast members are really throwing them. If you ever see an airplane going somewhere
德怀特、安琪拉和艾伦，我们扔的方式都差不多。所以我知道那是真的纸飞机，但我也知道他们在剪辑时稍微润色了一下。是的，我的意思是，答案是它们不是CGI飞机。它们全都是真的。而且你知道，演员们也确实在扔。如果你看到一架飞机飞向某个地方
and it's just the airplane, that was probably thrown by someone else, one of the professionals, you know, so that it would hit a certain mark. But it was a lot of fun. I mean, it's fun to throw a paper airplane that you know is good. It is.
而画面里只有飞机，那可能就是别人扔的，专业人士之一，你知道的，这样它才能命中某个目标。但真的很有趣。我是说，扔出一架你知道飞得很好的纸飞机是很有趣的。确实如此。
And you know, I don't know if you remember this, Jenna, but we all made a paper airplane ourselves. And I threw my paper airplane, and it went nowhere. Like, nose-dived. And then I threw one of airplane and it went nowhere. Like nose dived. And then I threw one of the ones they made and it was like astonishing. It flew almost the whole entire length of the warehouse.
你知道的，我不知道你还记不记得，珍妮，我们其实都自己折了一架纸飞机。然后我扔了我的纸飞机，结果根本没飞多远。就像垂直俯冲一样。然后我扔了一架他们制作的飞机，结果简直令人惊叹。它几乎飞了整个仓库的长度。
In fact, I feel like they had to tone it down a little. They're like, make them not go so far guys. You're making them too good. Yeah. All right, next up, let's go to Andy's eyeball. Yeah. Andy's gonna find out that the next scene requires him to hold his eyelids open
事实上，我觉得他们不得不稍微收敛一点。他们就像是，伙计们，别让它们飞那么远。你们把它们做得太好了。好吧，接下来，让我们来看看安迪的眼球。是的。安迪将发现接下来的场景需要他撑开眼皮，
and flesh out his eyes as a way of demonstrating what happens if you get a chemical in your eye. You have to use the eye wash station. And we should say, he didn't have to have any chemicals put in his eye. He was simply just going to rinse his eyes out with water. Yes, but Andy does not like eye stuff. There was a scene earlier where he's confronted with Toby's gooey eye,
并睁大眼睛，以此来演示如果不小心把化学品溅进眼睛里会发生什么。你必须使用洗眼站。我们得说明一下，他不需要把任何化学品弄进眼睛里。他只是要用清水冲洗眼睛。是的，但安迪不喜欢跟眼睛有关的东西。前面有一个场景，他面对托比那黏糊糊的眼睛，
and he can't even take it. He's not comfortable doing his own stunts. He wonders if there's gonna be CGI water that they're gonna add in later, and they're like, no, you just have to do this. Well, in the episode, we're gonna go back to the paper airplane contest, but why don't we stay here with Andy and his eyes?
他甚至都无法接受。他很不习惯自己做特技。他在想会不会有他们之后会添加的CGI水，而他们却说，不，你必须亲自做。好吧，在这一集中，我们将回到纸飞机比赛，但我们为什么不留在这里看安迪和他的眼睛呢?
Well, you know, Halstead shared with us that they knew Ed was great at physical comedy and freaking out. You know, in the episode he and Warren wrote Cafe Disco, there's this scene at the end where Kelly starts to pierce Andy's ear and he starts to yell and they cut away. So they knew that Ed playing Andy freaked out was going to be a home run. Nice. Well, we got some fan questions about the eye wash scene. EVL from Texas said, did Ed Helms really put his eye in the eye wash? The answer is yes. Yeah.
好吧，你知道的，霍尔斯特德跟我们分享过，他们知道埃德很擅长肢体喜剧和大惊小怪。你知道，在他和沃伦共同编剧的《咖啡迪斯科》这一集里，结尾有这样一个场景：凯莉开始给安迪穿耳洞，他开始大喊大叫，然后镜头切开了。所以他们知道埃德扮演安迪大惊小怪绝对会大获成功。太棒了。好吧，我们收到了一些关于洗眼场景的粉丝提问。德克萨斯州的EVL问，埃德·赫尔姆斯真的把眼睛放进洗眼器里了吗？答案是肯定的。是的。
Steve Burgess said this was a real eye wash station. We changed the signage to avoid any clearance issues, but that's what they look like. And our special effects guys fed it water that was a distilled sterile water. So they knew that it would be safe for Ed, but he really did it. And it's so funny. I mean, Daryl is there and Andy puts his face
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说这是一个真正的洗眼站。我们更改了标牌以避免任何版权问题，但它们看起来就是那个样子的。我们的特效人员提供的是蒸馏纯净水。所以他们知道这对埃德来说是安全的，但他确实这么做了。而且太搞笑了。我是说，达里尔也在场，安迪把脸
into this water and the whole time he is screaming and then he sits up and they're like, that was great. We can take out the screams and post. So, so good. I know, he's so funny. And Carla's very pleased. Carla is like, kid can act. Loved that line too.
浸入这水中，全程都在尖叫，然后他坐起来，他们就说，太棒了。我们可以在后期把尖叫声消掉。太棒了。我知道，他太搞笑了。卡拉非常满意。卡拉就像是在说，这小子真会演。我也很喜欢这句台词。
Me too. The kid can act. Get him a chair. Yeah, my actor sit. Well, now it's time for Toby and Angela to face off. Angela's gonna go first and has a fantastic throw. And if you go to 12 minutes and 39 seconds, that sort of yelp slash squeal that I make,
我也是。这小子真会演。给他一把椅子。是的，我的演员专属座位。好吧，现在轮到托比和安琪拉对决了。安琪拉先上场，投掷表现非常棒。如果你看12分39秒，我发出的那种类似于尖叫/尖叫的声音，
I'm like, ah! Yes. It's real because I was so excited because I got to use one of those professional paper airplanes and it went really far. That's my real reaction. I really threw that and that's where it landed. Well, I couldn't help but notice how long your plane stayed in the air and it's about 4.5 seconds.
我当时就在喊，啊！是的。那是真的，因为我太兴奋了，因为我用到了其中一架专业的纸飞机，而且它飞得非常远。那是我的真实反应。我真的是那样扔的，那就是它落地的地方。好吧，我不禁注意到你的飞机在空中停留了多久，大约是4.5秒。
Thank you. I mean, I should say thank you, professional paper airplane people. Well, I'll have you know that in addition to a contest for how far your plane can go, there's also a world record for the longest flight time. So how long it stays in the air. That makes sense to me.
谢谢。我是说，我应该对专业纸飞机的人说谢谢。好吧，我要告诉你的是，除了比飞机能飞多远的比赛之外，还有一个关于飞行时间最长的世界纪录。也就是它在空中停留的时间。这对我来说说得通。
And that record is currently held by Takua Toda from Japan. It was set in December 2010. And this paper plane stayed in the air for 29.2 seconds. Wow. At first, I thought you were going to say 29 minutes, and I was about to fall out of my chair. Oh, my goodness. I was like where's what that's impressive though. Yes but I mean to get a sense of how long that plane flew if you're watching this scene and you're watching Angela's airplane imagine if that scene went on five times longer. It's almost the same amount of time that Jim and Pam were silent on Boo's Cruise.
而这项纪录目前由来自日本的户田拓夫保持。它是在2010年12月创造的。这架纸飞机在空中停留了29.2秒。哇。起初，我还以为你要说29分钟，我都差点从椅子上摔下来。哦，天哪。我当时在想，这太让人印象深刻了。是的，不过为了让你感受一下那架飞机飞了多久，如果你正在看这个场景，看着安琪拉的飞机，想象一下那个场景延长五倍。这几乎和吉姆和帕姆在《布鲁斯巡游》上保持沉默的时间一样长。
That's right. That was like 21 seconds. Mm-hmm. It's longer. It's the longest airplane flew longer than Jim and Pam's moment of silence. Mm-hmm. Oh, I hope we didn't ruin that scene for people. Now when they go back to watch that, they're gonna think, imagine a paper airplane flying through the air. Sorry. Here's the thing with Jenna and I doing this rewatch and watching these episodes so many times, it's the office just lives in us now. It lives in my brain.
没错。那大约是21秒。嗯。时间更长。这架飞机飞的时间比吉姆和帕姆保持沉默的时刻还要长。嗯。哦，我希望我们没有毁掉大家的这一幕。现在当他们回去重看那一幕时，他们会想，想象一下一架纸飞机在空中飞行。抱歉。这就是我和珍妮一遍又遍重看这些剧集的原因，办公室已经融入了我们的生活。它就活在我的脑海里。
We relate everything back to like an episode. We're probably so annoying to be around. Well, it's Toby's turn now and he's just already defeated. He just crumples it up and he bails basically. So Angela wins. Dwight applauds. He's very happy. And Esther clocks this. She says, why are we happy for that little woman? And then Dwight says, you know, I pity her because she could have had everything and she lost it all. Yeah. And now we're going to see Dwight face off against Erin and guess who wins? Dwight!
我们把每件事都和某一集联系起来。周围的人可能觉得我们很烦人。好吧，现在轮到托比了，他已经彻底认输了。他直接把飞机揉成一团，基本上就是放弃了。所以安琪拉赢了。德怀特鼓掌。他非常高兴。埃斯特注意到了这一点。她说，我们为什么要为那个小个子女人高兴？然后德怀特说，你知道，我同情她，因为她本可以拥有一切，却把一切都失去了。是的。现在我们要看德怀特对阵艾伦，猜猜谁赢了？德怀特！
Ellie Kemper's reaction to losing. I had to watch this scene over and over and over. When she kicks that box and her foot gets stuck and then she loses her shoe and all the popcorn. Yes. It was so funny. And she's just like, I'm just really mad right now. I'm just really mad right now. I'm angry. And like, clearly that wasn't supposed to happen.
埃莉·肯珀落败时的反应。这个场景我看了又看、看又看、看了又看。当她踢那个箱子，脚被卡住，然后鞋子掉了出来，爆米花散落一地。是的。太搞笑了。她就像是在说，我现在真的很生气。我现在真的很生气。我很生气。而且，显然这不应该是这样的。
I don't think her foot was meant to break that box. I don't think she was meant to lose her shoe. And the two of them hold it together so well. It's beautiful. It is. And I just loved what Warren and Halstead shared with us about how important this story is for the Erin and Pete relationship
我觉得她的脚不是故意要把那个箱子踢坏的。我觉得她不是故意要弄丢鞋子的。他们两个配合得太好了。太精彩了。确实如此。我特别喜欢沃伦和霍尔斯特德跟我们分享的内容，关于这个故事对于艾伦和皮特的关系有多重要，
that Pete is now starting to question it. He's like, maybe we're not the right fit. Well, they said they were starting to think that Pete and Erin would not end up together. Yes. And so they had to show a way that maybe they weren't compatible. That's right.
即皮特现在开始产生质疑了。他觉得，也许我们并不适合彼此。是的，他们说他们开始觉得皮特和艾伦不会走到一起。没错。所以他们必须展示出某种他们可能并不合拍的方式。正是如此。
Well, now we're back at Jim and Pam and Clark's desk clump, and Jim and Pam are continuing to speak in their therapy speak, and it's becoming more passive aggressive. And Clark is like, hey, are you guys high? Because if you're high, can you pass me some? And they're like, no, we're not high. Yeah, this is when Pam is gonna have her talking head
好吧，现在我们回到了吉姆、帕姆和克拉克的办公桌区，吉姆和帕姆继续用他们的心理治疗话术交谈，而且变得越来越具有被动攻击性。克拉克说，嘿，你们俩吸了吗？如果你们吸了，能分我一点吗？他们说，不，我们没有吸。是的，这就是帕姆将要发表她的单人访谈的时候，
where she says, I just wish we'd started this exercise six months ago because my heart feels just blocked up right now. Yeah, I felt that when she said it. I felt it. I did too. I want you to know that there was more to this talking head. She would have gone on to say, I want to believe talking like robots will help, although robots aren't really known for their emotional connections. And are you ready for this, Angela?
她说，我只希望我们六个月前就开始做这个练习了，因为我的心现在感觉被堵得死死的。是的，她说这话时我感同身受。我感同身受。我也是。我想让你们知道，这段单人访谈里还有更多内容。她本会接着说，我想相信像机器人一样说话会有所帮助，尽管机器人并不是真的以情感联系著称。你准备好了吗，安琪拉？
No, I'm not. This is what Pam would have said next. Well, I guess R2-D2 and C-3PO were pretty attached. Ah! Is that where we're headed? She would have made a Star Wars reference! Star Wars and Lord of the Rings in one episode. Come on. I know it looks like Pam and Angela could be bonding over their love of sci fi films. That's a scene I
不，我没准备好。这是帕姆接下来要说的话。好吧，我猜R2-D2和C-3PO感情挺深的。啊！这就是我们要去的地方吗？她竟然引用了《星球大战》！一集里既有《星球大战》又有《指环王》。得了吧。我知道这看起来像是帕姆和安琪拉因为对科幻电影的共同喜爱而拉近了距离。这是我想看的场景。
want to see. I want to see the two of them in the break room talking sci fi.. Mm-hmm. Kevin is still working really hard on paper airplanes. There is a whole table of airplanes, and now he's gluing stuff, he's pasting things together. It's such a mess. This is like crafting gone wrong. This scene is completely unnecessary for the plot of this episode,
我想看她们俩在茶水间谈论科幻。嗯。凯文仍在非常努力地制作纸飞机。有一整张桌子的飞机，现在他在粘东西，把东西拼凑在一起。这简直是一团糟。这就像是手工制作出了问题。这个场景对于这一集的剧情来说完全是多余的，
but it is an absolute delight. It is a display of beautiful comic timing, both physical and oral. Is that a type of comedy? Oral comedy? I guess it is. Anyway, all of his timing is beautiful. I really enjoyed this moment. It's now time for the final round. It is Angela versus Dwight. Dwight had a talking head that was deleted and he talks about why he doesn't need the money but Angela does and I thought you should hear it.
但它绝对是一个极大的乐趣。它展现了精湛的喜剧时机，无论是肢体上的还是语言上的。这是一种喜剧吗？语言喜剧？我想是的。不管怎样，他所有的时机都把握得很完美。我真的很享受这一刻。现在是决赛轮了。是安琪拉对阵德怀特。德怀特有一段被删掉的单人访谈，他在里面谈到为什么他不需要这笔钱但安琪拉需要，我觉得你应该听听。
I don't need this win. I've got a lucrative job, an enormous farm, and this building. Angela has nothing but a child who, while adorable, won't bring in revenue for another five or six years. That's so interesting. It's very shrewd, isn't it, that he thinks Philip is gonna be working in five years? It is, but he's, you know, yeah. He has an interesting way of attaching value to things. Well, Angela's first throw is terrible.
我不需要这场胜利。我有一份利润丰厚的工作、一个巨大的农场，还有这栋大楼。安琪拉一无所有，只有一个孩子，虽然很可爱，但在未来五六年里不会带来任何收入。太有趣了。这不是很精明吗，他认为菲利普在五年内就要开始工作了？确实如此，但他，你知道，是的。他对事物价值的赋予方式很独特。好吧，安琪拉的第一投太糟糕了。
And then Dwight fumbles his on purpose. Esther clocks this. It's said in the script, Esther sees Dwight do this and is jealous. Yes, that's what it said in the shooting draft. And then she goes over to Angela and she's very patronizing and says, you know, they want her to win.
然后德怀特故意把球弄砸了。埃斯特注意到了这一点。剧本里写着，埃斯特看到德怀特这么做，并且很嫉妒。是的，拍摄剧本上就是这么写的。然后她走到安琪拉面前，语气非常居高临下地说，你知道的，他们希望她赢。
They know she needs this money, so use it wisely. And then Esther strokes sort of the back of Angela's hair. That was not scripted. Nora improvised that. And then I reacted and improvised as Angela would react, which is horrified that this woman has touched her hair. It was so fun. When Nora did it, we
他们知道她需要这笔钱，所以要明智地使用它。然后埃斯特顺势摸了摸安琪拉的头发后面。那不是剧本里有的。诺拉是即兴发挥的。然后我做出了反应，并以安琪拉会有的反应进行了即兴表演，那就是对这个女人居然碰了她的头发感到震惊。太有趣了。诺拉做这个动作时，我们
were like, okay, you've got to keep doing that. And then Angela goes over to Dwight and she says, do not tank this. Like she doesn't want his pity. Well, at first she's very delighted by the gesture, but when Esther gets involved, she's like, no, her pride comes out. That's right. Angela is going to go up to Dwight now and says, do not tank this throw. And so he throws and it goes far. And then she purposely tanks hers. I love this moment because Nora had improvised touching the back of my hair. We knew I had to touch her head somehow.
就觉得，好吧，你得继续这样做。然后安琪拉走向德怀特说，别故意输掉。就像她不需要他的同情一样。嗯，起初她对这个举动很高兴，但当埃斯特介入时，她就想，不，她的傲慢表现出来了。没错。安琪拉现在要走到德怀特面前说，不要故意投输。于是他投了，而且飞得很远。然后她故意把自己的给投砸了。我很喜欢这个时刻，因为诺拉即兴摸了我头发的后面。我们知道我得想法设法碰她的头。
Yeah, but she's so much taller than me. So Angela goes up to Esther and says, I guess you guys needed the money more than me. And then I improvise, huh, use it wisely. And I touched her forehead and hair and I saunter off very pridefully. So that was a really fun back and forth that I got to have with Nora.
是的，但她比我高太多了。所以安琪拉走到埃斯特面前说，我猜你们比我更需要这笔钱。然后我即兴发挥，哼，明智地使用它。我摸了摸她的额头和头发，然后非常高傲地走了开去。所以那真是一段非常有趣的互动，我和诺拉有了这样的交锋。
I love that she did that. And then I love that I got to have that response. Well, I love this whole moment. I really didn't know what was going to happen. I didn't know if Dwight was going to find a way to let Angela win, but I all of it was just so in character for you guys. And I think that's what I liked about it. I also love Angela's talking head when she's like, you know what Dwight showed weakness today and I don't need it. I don't need his pity. I have my dignity. And as she's saying it, she's stealing all the toilet paper from the bathroom. It did say in the script that even as she walks out with all that toilet paper, she's holding her head high. Yes, I read that too. Well, that's the end of our paper airplane storyline. And just to wrap things up, I thought y'all might like to know that the largest flying
我很高兴她这么做了。然后我也很高兴我能做出那样的回应。好吧，我很喜欢这个时刻。我真的不知道会发生什么。我不知道德怀特会不会想办法让安琪拉赢，但这一切都太符合你们的角色设定了。我想这就是我喜欢它的原因。我也很喜欢安琪拉的单人访谈，当时她说，你知道吗，德怀特今天表现出了软弱，而我不需要这个。我不需要他的同情。我有我的尊严。就在她说这话的同时，她正在偷走洗手家里所有的卫生纸。剧本里确实写过，即使她拿着那么多卫生纸走出去，她依然昂着头。是的，我也读到了。好吧，我们的纸飞机故事线到此结束。为了做个总结，我想大家可能会想知道，最大飞行的
paper airplane is a 53-pound paper glider that flew 59 feet. It has a wingspan of 60 feet, a length of 17 feet, and it was constructed in Germany in 2013 by a team of 16 university students and employees. A larger paper airplane was built in Fitchburg, USA in 2018, but it was not able to fly. Ah. Yes. And that concludes your paper airplane tidbits. I loved them. Thank you very much.
纸飞机是一个53磅重的纸质滑翔机，飞行了59英尺。它的翼展为60英尺，长度为17英尺，由16名大学生和员工组成的团队于2013年在德国建造。2018年，美国菲奇堡建造了一架更大的纸飞机，但它没能飞起来。啊。是的。这就是你们的纸飞机冷知识。我很喜欢。非常感谢。
The next scene made me tear up and I was not expecting it. I was sort of surprised. I hadn't seen this episode since it aired. And this whole Jim and Pam ending really got me, lady. You know, Jim is going to tell Pam that he's sorry that he has to go. It's time for him to go back to Philly, but he thinks they should keep working at this because they're making progress. And he kind of does that thing where he looks back, but she doesn't. And then he leaves and then she looks towards the door, but he's already left. And then
接下来的场景让我泪流满面，这是我没有料到的。我有点吃惊。自从这一集播出以来，我还没看过它。吉姆和帕姆的整个结局真的触动了我，女士。你知道，吉姆要告诉帕姆他很遗憾必须离开。是时候回费利205：城了，但他认为他们应该继续努力，因为他们正在取得进展。他做了一个他回头看但她没有看他的动作。然后他离开了，接着她望向门口，但他已经离开了。然后
she sees that he left his umbrella and she hesitates for a second and decides to try to catch him to give it to him. Well, that scene at the desk where Jim comes really close to Pam, I remember when we were shooting this that this is the first time that our characters had been in one another's intimate personal space in a really long time. Yeah.
她看到他落下了雨伞，犹豫了一秒钟，决定去追他把伞还给他。好吧，在吉姆靠帕姆非常近的那张桌子旁，我记得我们在拍这一幕时，这是我们的角色在很长一段时间里第一次进入彼此的亲密个人空间。是的。
And not only was he in her sort of close proximity, but he was gentle. He kneeled down. He was next to her. He was being earnest. There was a connection between the two of them in that moment that we haven't seen in many episodes. He was being Jim.
不仅他离她很近，而且他很温柔。他单膝跪地。他就在她身边。他是真诚的。那一刻他们两人之间有一种我们在很多集里都没有见过的联系。他当时就是吉姆。
He was being old Jim. All of the posturing of Athlead was gone. And he was being the guy that she fell in love with. That's right. And it was very moving to me. And it was hard for me to not kind of melt in that moment as Pam, you know? Because she's wanted this for a really long time.
他就是以前那个吉姆。Athlead的所有做作姿态都消失了。他变成了那个她爱上的男人。没错。这让我非常感动。作为帕姆，那一刻我很难不融化，你知道吗？因为她已经渴望这个很久了。
So this was a really fun scene to play. It had a lot of levels. And then it leads to this scene in the parking lot. Pam decides to run out and give Jim his umbrella. And he hugs her? And I wrote this to you, Jenna. We were trading texts. I said, Jim hugs Pam like she's the last life preserver on the Titanic.
所以这一幕演起来非常有趣。它有很多层次。然后它导向了停车场里的这一幕。帕姆决定跑出去把雨伞给吉姆。他拥抱了她？我把这个写给你了，珍妮。我们在发短信交流。我说，吉姆拥抱帕姆的样子，就像她是泰坦尼克号上最后一块救生圈。
I know. He grabbed onto her. He does. And this is just such a beautiful scene. Pam is resistant at first and he just will not let her go until she breaks down that wall and she hugs him back and they kiss and they say I love you. I teared up. I know and they have this flashback to their wedding of Jim's brother, you know, reading from Corinthians. And you know, that footage didn't exist.
我知道。他紧紧抓住她。他确实是。这真是一个美丽的场景。帕姆一开始是抗拒的，而他就是不肯放手，直到她打破了那堵墙，她回抱了他，他们亲吻了，他们说我爱你。我哭了。我知道，他们闪回了吉姆兄弟婚礼的场景，你知道的，宣读着哥林多前书。而且你知道，那段素材本来是不存在的。
We had to bring Blake Robbins in and set up the church, just that one corner of the church. And he had to do that reading. We shot that just for this episode. All the other footage was footage that we already had from that episode. But this was really beautiful. You know, we had a fan question from Marie R.
我们不得不把布莱克·罗宾斯请来，布置教堂，就教堂的那一个角落。他不得不读那段经文。我们专门为这一集拍摄了那一幕。所有其他素材都是我们从那一集里已经有的素材。但这真的非常美好。你知道的，我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州奥马哈的玛丽·R.的粉丝提问，
in Omaha, Nebraska, who said, in the last scene where Jim and Pam hug and then kiss and remember their wedding, I noticed that it was in the parking lot where Jim first professed his love for Pam on casino night. Was this intentional or just a coincidence? Marie, this was intentional. Yeah.
她说，在最后一幕中，吉姆和帕姆拥抱然后亲吻并回忆他们的婚礼时，我注意到那是吉姆在赌场之夜第一次向帕姆表白爱意的停车场。这是刻意安排的还是纯属巧合？玛丽，这是刻意安排的。是的。
It's there. It's happening in the same spot. This is such a wonderful bookends for their story, kind of the first moment that Jim said, I'm in love with you, and then here in the parking lot again to save the marriage. It's just really beautiful writing. Yeah.
它就在那里。它发生在同一个地方。这对他们的故事来说是一个绝妙的呼应，就像吉姆说“我爱上你了”的第一个时刻，然后又在这里的停车场为了拯救婚姻而再次相聚。这真的是非常美妙的剧本编写。是的。
And we talked about this too, Angela. You see in that moment the way John Krasinski, as Jim, swoops down to get to Pam's level for that hug. That is a classic John Krasinski hugging move. We've talked about this before. He gives the best hugs. He gives such great hugs. He is just like that cozy blanket that makes you feel better. I know. I just love now that he's a dad and has little girls cause I know he hugs them like that, you know? I know, I thought the same thing.
我们之前也谈过这个，安琪拉。你在那一刻看到约翰·卡拉辛斯基扮演的吉姆为了那个拥抱而俯身迁就帕姆的高度。那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基经典的拥抱动作。我们以前讨论过这个。他的拥抱最棒了。他的拥抱太棒了。他就像那条让你感觉好受点儿的舒服毯子。我知道。我现在特别喜欢他当了爸爸，有了小女儿，因为我知道他就是那样抱她们的，你知道吗？我知道，我也是这么想的。
That's the hug you want. That's the hug that makes everything feel like it's gonna be okay. Yes, and it is that kind of hug. When he gives you a hug, it is like, oh my gosh, what was that bad day that I was having? Everything's gonna be fine. And that's how the episode ends, everybody.
那就是你想要的拥抱。那是能让一切都感觉会好起来的拥抱。是的，就是那种拥抱。当他给你一个拥抱时，感觉就像是，天哪，我刚才经历的糟糕的一天算什么？一切都会没事的。大家，这一集就这样结束了。
I mean, we have a lot of thank yous for this one. It was such a joy to rewatch. Thanks again to Steve Burgess for the call sheets and answering our questions. I really loved hearing from Warren and Halstead on this. One of the things they shared that I wanted to mention but forgot in the moment was they said they loved writing for Daryl and Andy for that friendship.
我是说，我们要对这一集表示很多的感谢。重看这一集真是一种享受。再次感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供通告单并回答我们的问题。我真的很喜欢听沃伦和霍尔斯特德谈论这个。他们分享的内容中，有一点我想提但当时忘了，那就是他们说他们非常喜欢为达里尔和安迪写他们的这段友情。
Yeah. And you really see it in this. I didn't bring it up, but I loved the pep talk that Daryl gave Andy when he said, "'Andy Bernard can't squirt water in his eye and act like it doesn't freak him out, but you know who can? Older male lab assistant number one.
是的。你在这集里真的能看出来。我没提这个，但我真的很喜欢达里尔给安迪的那番动员讲话，他说：“安迪·伯纳德不能把水喷进眼睛里还装作这没把他吓坏，但你知道谁能吗？一号年长男实验助理。
Yes. And Andy says, do you believe in me? And Darryl says, I believe I want to go home. Yeah, that was so good. Anyway, Warren and Halstead just said they loved writing for those two. And thank you, Warren and Halstead, for sharing everything you did about all the different storylines and the behind the scenes details. I also wanna thank my friend Pete Holney for sending in his audio clip. I love his stories.
是的，安迪说，你相信我吗？达里尔说，我相信我想回家。是的，那太棒了。不管怎样，沃伦和霍尔斯特德只是说他们非常喜欢为这两个角色写作。谢谢沃伦和霍尔斯特德，跟我们分享了关于所有不同故事线和幕后细节的一切。我也要感谢我的朋友皮特·霍尔尼发来的音频剪辑。我喜欢他的故事。
And I wanted to give a shout out. Pete said that him and his brother, you know, they were the twin elves in Elf. Yep. They do Christmas parties, lady, and corporate hootenannies. And I'll share in stories. If you want the two twin elves from Elf,
我想顺便喊话一下。皮特说他和他的兄弟，你知道的，他们是《圣诞精灵》里的双胞胎精灵。对。他们办圣诞派对，女士，还有公司大联欢。我会在故事里分享的。如果你想要《圣诞精灵》里的那两个双胞胎精灵，
they'll come to your party. That is so fun. I know, they have the costumes and everything. What a good idea. Well, I want to give a shout out to Halstead, who's got two exciting projects coming up I think everyone should be on the lookout for. The first is How to Die Alone, starring Natasha Rothwell,
他们会去你的派对。太有趣了。我知道，他们有服装和一切。真是个好主意。好吧，我要向霍尔斯特德喊话，他有两个令人兴奋的项目即将推出，我认为每个人都应该关注一下。第一个是娜塔莎·罗斯韦尔主演的《如何独自死去》，
which will premiere on Hulu on September lookout for. The first is How to Die Alone, starring Natasha Rothwell, which will premiere on Hulu on September 13th. And the other is a college comedy called Overcompensating, and it's starring Benito Skinner, AKA Benny Drama from Instagram, and that will premiere on Amazon sometime next year. Well, there you go. Thank you guys so much for sending in your questions and comments.
该剧将于9月13日在Hulu首播。另一个是一部名为《矫枉过正》的大学喜剧，由贝尼托·斯金纳主演，也就是Instagram上的本尼·德拉玛，该剧将于明年某个时候在Amazon首播。好了，就是这样。非常感谢大家发送你们的问题和评论。
We love you. Big thank you to Jenna and Cassie and Sean for recording on a Saturday morning so I can go do this fun project I can't wait to share about. Yeah, of course. And when we're back together, we should do a paper airplane contest. Yes!
我们爱你们。非常感谢珍妮、卡西和肖恩在周六早晨进行录制，这样我就可以去做那个我迫不及待想要分享的有趣项目了。是的，当然。等我们再聚在一起时，我们应该办一场纸飞机比赛。太好了！
Let's do it. But we have to fold them ourselves, Cassie. We can't get any pros coming in. I'll get the rules, okay? Okay. Alright everyone, have a great week. See you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
我们干吧。但我们必须自己折，卡西。我们不能请什么专业人士来。我去拿规则，好吗？好。好吧，各位，祝大家过个愉快的一周。下次见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的一档节目，由珍妮·费舍尔和安琪拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍妮·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。节目由克里斯·巴西尔进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。